[Music]
you just showed up like you might need
some practice
you going down for the count it's going
down tonight i do it all for my family
you do it all for the likes i hit that
bell and i'm ready to fight turn me up
turn me up turn me up they want the belt
they don't work and
[Music]
[Applause]
what's up fam welcome to calabasas fight
companion for the very first bkfc bare
knuckle fighting championship in london
it's about to go down i'm here with two
of
my favorite people on the goddamn planet
to my left is the mythical legend the
machine himself
the guy who has been just absolutely
great to me
uh
you're the man it's bert kreicher the
machine i am this is my first drink in
five days
really is it really i went really hard
at mark norton i kind of feel honored i
almost went too hard i went i went so
hard i thought i got coveted oh my god
yeah like like the last day i don't know
we got ivs and something didn't connect
with me on the iv and i ended up in bed
for a day
and uh and then came home didn't drink
on the flight
but uh we'll talk about that we'll talk
about that yeah
they thought you had monkey pox i got
this
portable kool-aids because i care about
you are those iv packs those are those
are sugar-free on-the-go kool-aids i
absolutely love it
i'll just let you know it's full don't
later ever throw them in your bag
yesterday was national kool-aid day was
it really national kool-aid day yeah
it's great it's national kool-aid and
it's zero sugar gluten free non-gmo
vegan free all of that [__] it's so
[__] do you enjoy cooling introduce
our next guest so we can try too sorry
you're right it's not too late man i
enjoyed it
and then the man sitting across from me
the legend matt's been on here a ton you
guys he's the pool dynasty owner he's
you know him from knocking out with the
grace to ever do it he knocked out fade
or you son of a [__]
all right it is the ufc bellator legend
it is matt matrio
what's up everybody what's up bellator's
so much more accessible
uh yeah for sure and like like so here's
how let me hurt a little bit in hot this
is by the way i know nothing about
anything that's right yeah yeah yeah i
know nothing i thought mike perry was
mike chandler
they they fight the same style do they
really because michael chandler's a fun
guy to watch they fight the same michael
pearl by the way i'm a fan of michael
perry's tmz so yeah we'll talk about
that one second mike perry mike mike
perry
see mvp and mike perry they're so almost
they're like so he's so different
fighting style yang but they have the
same initials so it really makes you
want to say [__] it
but the thing i like about
the thing i like about bellator is
like
you ever date a chick
that you dated in high school a little
bit and then you guys hooked back up
like after college and you forgot that
you knew how to kiss together yeah
that's what bellator is because then
you're like oh [__] i know that guy yeah
i watched that guy in the ufc i was a
fan of him and then he just where'd he
go yeah he's back in bellator because he
is from the older guys
what that was i just want the guy what's
the what's the [__] redneck that you
fought with the long hair
uh the [__] nelson
it's dope it's where legends go to die
or names go to die bellatories yeah but
what's kind of cool about it like when i
went to bellator i remember i fought in
london right so i fought like three
weeks ago ahead before that i fought in
st louis then i'm like hey we have a
fight for you in london if you want to
jump in that and i was like yeah sure
that [__] sounds great so i went to
london and you guys have been in london
a thousand times you know how bad the
traffic is there awful so like we had to
leave like three and a half four hours
in advance in order just to get to the
venue and then you're doing it it's like
three or four hours to wait for your
fight and i was like dude i don't want
to do that they're like cool man don't
worry about it just show up by this time
cool
yeah it's really useful you never let
your
ufc is like uh
the one thing about the ufc is like it's
a well-oiled machine like it's you're in
the nfl for mixed martial arts like it
is it is scheduled like they run the
circus and they run it better than
anybody in the world yeah i can't
imagine what anxiety i'd have the day
before a fight just doing a special when
i'm shooting like i'll shoot four if i
do a special i shoot four
that anxiety
it builds up it's like a weird thing
it's like uh like i remember the first
time i ever got i remember i got it so
bad on last comic standing too that i
actually said what the [__] you were on
the show or it was on last couple of
days no no i was on last coming saying
two this is probably yeah years ago 19
years ago really yeah yeah and uh
it was at a theater and my ass was
sweating so bad it was running down my
it was like pouring down my legs and i
was shaking and granted i was eating a
lot of xanax at the time and drinking a
lot of red bull it was definitely as it
did to the xanax i was a hardcore
technical time like back when i was like
now i can't even do it like i did but i
would take a [__] full bar a sandy
bar and just start drinking at an
airport the i had to stop because my
sister
said i will not pick you up from the
airport i don't know who i'm speaking to
in the car oh no oh dude it's the
greatest drug in the world like if you
could pick to sleep to chill and sleep
it's like the lord made a drug it was
xanax like it takes all the [__]
guesswork out of everything it's like
like an edible you're like well is this
going to be fun is this going to be too
much
it's it's perfectly portioned i mean i
wish i could give it i've never taken
zany in my life ever never taken xanny
or cocaine in my life ever oh my god
those are the two best but [__] i'm a
psychedelic i'm shrooms and acid like oh
my god that's where i go assumes an acid
is like a chick uh with with uh with uh
long sharp nails
you know and you're like i don't know
what i'm getting here either the best
[__] of my life or i'm getting into a
fight
dude
with zany it just i don't get how people
function on it like if i have really bad
anxiety at work or something's coming up
i'll take you to sleep and that's it
yeah you have to take well let's be very
clear if you're gonna take a xanax you
have to take it at like
4 6 p.m and then your day's over don't
take one in the morning and think you're
getting through your day i took a xanax
for bob and tom one time
indianapolis by the way it was so bad i
mean it was so bad
that like i couldn't fight i remember
was like i i don't even know like little
wayne on lean
i would love to try this
dude i know paul wall and i told him
because he came on king this thing
before yeah i'm like dude i need some
lean he's like well
yeah if you come down here we'll hook
you up man i'm like bro say less i'm
there in october let's go
i like to party just just a little bit
of extra cough syrup yeah is so much fun
like i remember had a chest infection
and i was at the improv and like you
can't drink but take this cough syrup
it'll get rid of your coffee so i took
it for the perform yeah and then i took
a little more after and i was like okay
this is enjoyable
i got to get into this i could commit to
this and you know what sells me on it is
when they mix the drinks and it looks
like uh like a surprise no keynote it's
the white cup with the lamb
hold on hold on stop get it preparation
of a drink for me sells it so the thing
that got me on kool-aid i was at costco
uh a smart final and smart and final had
32 ounce uh uh styrofoam cups and i was
like [__] i'm gonna grab some
thirty years old
they're the best to drink a drink in
ever so i go home leanne gets me crushed
ice crushed ice nothing better crushed
ice and i got a zero sugar kool-aid and
i put it in and i went i'm having a
cocktail like this is like this is a
treat yeah that is what makes me that's
what sells me on lean they use styrofoam
cups jolly rancher in the bottom little
bit of sprite little bit of lean little
i mean it's like
it's a snow cone for adults sign me up
baby dude snow cones are [__] legit
have you had the ones in holly eva is
that the shaved ice one shave yeah
i like to chew on it whoa
all right hey cheers gentlemen first
drink in five days sounds good my friend
salute cheers boys appreciate you doing
thank you for having me on now you're
you're saying uh sorry matt you were
saying as far as the anxiety before a
special similar fight the the fight's
different like i get anxiety especially
for a big show especially early on for a
real big show
i was nervous
but
in fighting i remember i was fighting at
mgm grand and the main event was shane
carwin uh brock lesnar and shane was my
like my brother like my main training
partner and i'm in my hotel i'm freaking
out the guy i'm fighting chris tuscher's
20-1 right like whatever national
champion wrestler
yeah and i was like so the worst body
ever yeah so if you lose him you look
like a straight [__] because he's
tough he looks like chewed up bubble gum
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no
he looks like a bad guy from james bond
like he's still a nightmare right yeah
so he's just a
rough looking dude so anyways i'm in the
hotel and i'm panicking i got no sleep
the night before i'm pacing back forth
my anxiety through the [__] roof and
i was like oh and i usually like to be
by myself i'm like i'm gonna go upstairs
in shane because shane had the big sweep
he's fighting brock lesnar yeah so i go
up there just
to like ease my nerves i'm up there and
there's a scene here the entourage and
our coaches there and shane i just he's
i don't know if you've ever seen shane
caron he's gigantic i just see him
staring out at the mgm grand pool and he
was shot get over here and i walked up
and i'm like bro i'm so nervous and he's
like how are you again he looks out and
goes what the [__] are we doing
i go what he goes look at all those
people down there having fun in the pool
that could be us man instead we're
getting punched in the [__] face he
goes let's what are we doing i was like
uh you're making this way
worse there's no getting out there's no
constellation i was like you're the main
event right so we can't get out of this
i was like i'm going back to my room
dude
there is a moment i don't know how many
like i i can never compare my jobs to
what you guys do have done for a living
collectively stand up you can no no tell
you why if i did i did travel channel
and when i did travel and this is not
going to connect but like i had to do
dangerous [__] like i had a day where i
jumped off the tall stadium in africa
swim with great white sharks and then
you repelled off so you're so you're a
junkie kind of like you
chase it yeah you chase it not even
remotely
the reason i got the job is because i'm
hesitant and i'm a comic so i can talk
through it if you give it to a junkie he
just gets up he's like this is going to
be dope and then he just does it and
there's no you got you don't you know
comedy there's no there's no story
there's no narrative you get a guy who's
afraid to do it the anxiety you build up
you talk your way through it and he
connects to the person watching and he's
like and
and so that's why i got i did this show
called hurt burt where i took dangerous
men's jobs for a day i was an mma
fighter i fought the four gracies at
once i was they i got choked out by the
gracies i got choked out by uh one of
the h's i don't know [__] enzo it'd
be a
a professional football player i was a
dominatrix [__] and then i went on to
this i did all this was the best show of
all time it's it was a it was a [__]
great show still on the internet i got
mauled by a bull you can see it on fine
online yeah but to be to be fair so bert
was doing those tv shows like the travel
challenge doing all that yeah but he
wasn't focusing on like staying up in
common is that fair to say yeah very
fast and then because it took so much
time it was so demanding because it was
two weeks on and traveling around the
world like i go to tanzania and south
africa and and jump off
jump off buildings and jump off cliffs
and then do all this crazy [__] and then
uh and then i have one week home but you
gotta fly from africa to go home yeah
and then i'd spend that maybe i'd spend
that weekend at the orlando improv or
maybe i stay home and then i go out for
another two weeks family too so yeah
like in order to you know you to do set
your work to yeah so it's like you're
balancing this act that one's been so
difficult now did you did you see a hit
to your career or your trade for a
little while were you like man i'm just
not pulling this down or are you like i
miss the family i don't want to be gone
like that oh no no i was i've always
been blind to
family yeah like i don't mean that i
don't mean that callously but i go like
look there's dudes that go to go to war
for two years and then come home and
miss their kids there's dudes who you
know go and work on an oil rig i mean
there's certain things and there's women
that do that also there's certain things
i just realized e [__] catch check cash
checks pay for your family make sure
they're taken care of first and so i'm
not saying a superpower i think for you
bert well i don't know i don't know
i regret it at times but i just was like
you work you try to make money so you
can support your family and so that they
can have a good life and maybe they can
get nice things put them in through
college whatever and so i was
disconnected
entirely almost uh from
i just would like if i had emotion i
just shut it down have a cocktail yeah
and so it wasn't super healthy yeah but
that's where i'm at now yeah well
look [__] chris the stefano's there
like uh we talked me and stefano talked
about two bears about how hard it is
it's hard as [__] man and you think
about the regret you think about if
you're a fighter right yeah i mean you i
don't need to say that to you guys but
like you got a fight coming up you got
to commit everything you have to that
you got to go full rocky and go i'm
giving everything to that because if i
don't then i'm i'm shortchanging myself
my future my kids future my friends the
people that work with me the difference
between stand up the difference in
stand-up is it's like it's never there's
no off season
you can watch
all the time i can do sets monday
through sunday three sets an hour every
single night podcast during the day they
go on the road like you can you can book
that thing so that
you'll eventually you'll be like god why
did i commit to this you know what i'm
saying then your kids are like what the
[__]
hey dad it's my birthday next week oh
by the way but with
that is red electrical tape that is
gangster
anyways i'm sorry his name's hick but
with with bert so he was traveling doing
that like one foot in comedy one foot in
tv yeah and then is it fair to say bert
uh uh bill burr and rogan was like dude
quit doing that [__] you can make
more money doing podcasts in stanford
this is your money here
they were maybe not as kind in that
conversation but yeah they were like oh
this show sucks oh i'm oh i'm
paraphrasing yeah yeah yeah yeah oh
trust me
i know that talk yeah yeah several times
and so so
i think you might know this story so
like i actually hurt your feelings i
took am i hurting your feelings right
now is this hurting i was like you can't
i took the opposite direction where i
got brought up to a meeting in chicago
do you know the story about okay yeah so
i got brought up to a meeting in chicago
uh where they're like uh i sat down as
it was uh three girls one woman i knew
two women i didn't sit down in this
restaurant we're sitting there chopping
up and they're asking me all kinds of
questions very personal questions
whatever else hold on just for context
this is after he had bellator yeah this
is kind of that bellator
he's in between like fighting yeah that
guy's i'm going for the guy in the gold
shorts and the cornrows okay i'm going
for mom yeah i'm going to finish your
story um so anyway so i get brought up
there i know like hey man uh we sit down
we talk about all this stuff and it's a
long dinner uh let me tell you in my
pocket to pick up the tab i know like
hey man like don't this is this isn't
what you think it is i was like what do
you mean and the girl that i know
she's like okay ladies well what do you
guys think and they're like he's the one
he's the one we're talking about uh did
he catch that overhand right there no um
the boys are swinging
he's kind of guy gets adult braces
no he's the kind of kid where his mom
gave him away at two you know what i'm
saying like was it so much basket at the
firehouse they're so talented
so i get brought into this meeting and
then they talk about hey um you know
what
john cena's not pulling the same
audience that he used to and we're
interested uh demographically we need
somebody that has the look the attitude
the the street cred uh and the
personality to pull this thing off and
we think you're him and uh so that they
like hey man are you how do you feel
about this gig whatever else i'm like
man i gotta think about it they gave me
all these details and they're sexy
details man like really nice but i live
in indiana i grew up in illinois that
means my entire family has to move out
to la and then everything changes from
that point on there's nothing that's
ever going to be the same but kind of
lit yeah it would be dope for sure but
it's a drastic change right and if i
feel like i don't see my family now i'm
not going to see them going forwards
right yeah and my kids at this time were
probably my oldest is almost 17. so they
were probably like
12 uh
12 8 and something 12 nine and something
right totally seven and i was like dude
if i feel guilty now about being gone so
much i can't do it so i called him up
and told him i turned down the job then
they were like you sure man this is a
really a good opportunity whatever else
and i was like do i i just can't justify
it you know so i turned it down and you
know who has that gig now ben affleck he
was gonna be daredevil yeah
no i'm just kidding oh my god
you know like uh directs drax yeah in uh
batista it was the show he's in uh the
big ass movie the franchise yeah
guardians of the galaxy yeah it could be
new yeah so like i don't know if that i
don't know if that was that my my career
would have paralleled into that but when
i got when i offered that i was like do
i just i just don't want to put my kids
together i don't want to have that lunch
i will
never speak to my family again
by the way i can i will i will say
goodbye to them if you say if you say
here's the deal bro you got to get a new
family yeah well no family go no family
i'd be like it's it's really sorry i'll
tell my girl listen listen checks
i sign on i sign and do the next six
batman's okay check will be in the mail
every month okay daddy's going to
[__] think about a man like then you
like remember about putting the genie
back in the bottle yeah that my genie's
in the bottle like i live in a town of
35 000 people pretty nice so i wouldn't
mind that i wouldn't mind i've got it
but like well yeah but but peop you can
fantasize them i like my fantasy used to
be building fences
so like like i look at the [__] i know
like i saw
i'm driving through dc one time and i'm
i'm going from radio to radio getting on
a train going to new york or getting on
a plane going to new york doing press
press press all for like travel channel
[__] and it was like very stressful and
being brand friendly and not saying the
wrong thing and i was doing rachel ray
and good morning america and it was a
lot of stress and i remember looking at
this guy building a stone fence
and i thought
how [__] fast i wonder if he goes to
bed thinking about that fence or if when
he gets done today he goes cold beer at
the bar with the boys i'm not thinking
about work at all i see i think he's
looking at you going god i wish i could
be on everybody does
well plus like you got to think about
like if you've never had shine
all you want is shine like you want to
know the feeling or sensation of shine
right and then you can't give it back
dude you remember with the so in the ufc
they pick you up about two to three
hours before the fight yeah and you're
on this bus you're on one of those big
ass nice buses and you're driving to the
stadium that's when the nerves are just
like
and i remember you just and i'm just
staring like everything's quiet like
everyone's so serious everyone has their
headphones and it's so serious i
remember just it'd be like kind of
almost nighttime you're going through i
remember in toronto when we fought matt
yeah i remember driving through downtown
toronto
we fought each other we're driving
through downtown toronto i'm just
looking at everyone like and they're
just easy going walking i remember
staring into a starbucks looking at the
breeze i'm like i would give my left nut
to trade [__] positions with that
[__] barista right now that's funny i
wonder
i wonder if like i bet kevin hart
doesn't feel that new
like i bet he just goes yeah i'm where
i'm supposed to be well you think like
like
he also he felt all the pressure because
the squeeze came down on him right so i
bet now he's like [__] it he's like he
could give it away or i wonder if he's
in it now just to show everybody else
that they can't [__] stop him but
with guys like kevin kevin hart's kevin
hart's a different i i say this
respectfully he's a different man than
me
he is
he is a he's as far as what he does i
think i think i i think i have a lot i
have a lot more silver spoon life
compared to what he had to grow up with
he had he had a oh i must say that like
i met his brother one time
uh was this nice
how good is that movie how good is that
i haven't seen it dude kevin hart can do
no wrong is he the same tattoo that
conor mcgregor has
oh wow what do you think he did it
because of conor mcgregor do you think
conor mcgregor ever looks and goes
all right mate
well that's english yeah he's from
dublin right he's like okay there you go
hold on hold on i'll get it all right
i'm ready oh top of the boat and do you
okay do you think conor mcgregor was
like
wait start me on a conor mcgregor accent
real quick uh
he would get
i'm not here to take over
the cloak you sound like uh you sound
like a beast
oh yeah
patty the baddie and i are in the same
[__] boat i identify with i identify
with fighters so often
because patty the batter is like
scousers don't get knocked out and i'm
always like i'll never quit drinking yes
one day patty and i are going to be in a
hospital bed next to each other going it
turns out this liver does give up do you
know him at all no i love that guy you
two together would be insane we we have
the same we have the same uh brain when
it comes to food he's so guardian he's
his energy he seems so genuine he's he
hope he doesn't get jaded i hope he's
looking i'm telling him
he makes me like molly the meatball a
lot are they dating would you say no no
no no no
they're always together they're training
partners i like her a lot like i like
and i don't i don't mean this wrong but
i don't like i don't follow a lot of a
ton of like female fights i just don't
yeah it's i just don't i get it i don't
mean that negative but i'm just don't i
know i'm going to tell you you have to
justify that i know i meant to tell you
guys uh tate fletcher got kicked off
instagram facebook uh today yeah one
more i'm gonna see him tonight yeah what
taking kicked off seeing him tonight
what are you guys doing tonight other
than the show it's my wife's
52nd birthday had a boy i rented uh she
said she want to have a dance party so i
rented a 25 by 25 foot dance floor for
our backyard i got a dj carter cruise
and i invited a small group of her
friends girls just all old ladies you
don't want just all labels i don't know
boys i think it's just all ladies oh wow
and they're just dancing to fleetwood
mac all night in our backyard wow but
oh not tate fletcher not i'm sorry not
to [__] take pictures
wow
andrew take oh i'm sorry
because of the hustle you have autism
it's it's [__] andrew because of the
big boy by the way
because it was such because he was
running that pyramid
you've never seen love on the spectrum
you don't know the different spectrums
well dude do you think they get all
their names right
you think they get all the names right
oh no you know what it is
just like yeah you know what it is
you know what it is
tate fletcher's
girlfriend is my trainer lacey mackey so
let's clear it up so tate fletcher was a
mixed martial artist out of jackson's a
really good dude and he also works in
movies
and an actor and
and and one of rogan's best friends and
has one of the best [__] umaplata
stories i've ever heard in my entire
life but also it has the best smelling
beard of all time i don't know what she
shaved it off and has a great jawline so
it was weird i just saw a picture of him
at disney world sorry
yeah he's a good looking dude i've been
around him no that's not true i've i've
been in that same circle for a long time
and i've never once met him i don't
think he's such a good dad we always run
and we just kind of miss each other but
like i think we follow each other
instagram never met each other but i
think there's like a mutual respect i
just never came across your uh social
media buddies it's yeah it's because i
live in indiana that's why but but
there's also no there's a group talking
to you from michigan i talked to him
about when he moved out here and i was
like dude that's a really big move man
like how do you feel about that and he
was like you know i'm a little anxious
about it but i feel like this is a place
where i can really kind of start my next
life and you've just flourished into it
you really have you really have i you do
things that i'm scared to do like i like
like
i'm trying to keep up with you how many
rounds are there i get office spaces i'm
i'm so i do everything in my house i'm
you know you've been to my place i'm i'm
always scared to spend money you and
segura
have i'm always scared to spend money
your house makes the difference well my
house is different the best house i've
ever seen that's leanne's money
i'm saying like
yeah leanne spends money like a
[__]
keep working and has my girl leanne i
have a friend that won't say his name
but but i remember his i said he fell
into some money i said how's
uh
what's that like and he goes well let's
just say my wife is taken to spending
money very well
and and uh he used to and uh but leanne
leanne's one of those people that she
looks at numbers looks at things and
goes we can afford this we're getting it
and so she looked at that house she got
a great deal on a lot and then was like
i know we can get this for this price
point let's do it and so
i don't have i have no idea what money
is it's my favorite house that your
house is oh really
thank you thank you so you guys
customers you guys custom built it we
got really [__] lucky
and leanne like we found a lot it's it's
uh
it's a big lot and leanne wrote a letter
to the lady that was selling it and then
went over and like leanne's like hustler
yeah and her and our
real estate agent were gangsters they
got it for a good price the lot and then
we kept the house out of the second
story out of the gym onto the back it's
so dope and kept your shoulders back
there
my studio is there it's really it's
it's where i'll die
by the way it's where i think it's gonna
is where they were gonna die but you
were saying me and tom aren't afraid to
spend money you and tom
i wish i had that i wish i had more of
that because i go like you go to tom you
go to this uh your mom's house studios
in austin and it's just top-notch it's
top-notch cameras
i mean everything your mom's house
that's tommy thomas
and he lives down in austin he lives
yeah he lives out yeah
that's that's chased him yeah yeah so
yeah joe said tom you need to move here
and thompson backbone yeah so he moved
there yeah he's sucking he was like he
was like was
you're the man joe you make the calls
i'm not a grown man i'll go to austin
i'll suck you off every monday wednesday
friday sure thing can i get on your
podcast once a year i know i'm not that
good at it but thanks
so much so yeah tom went down to tom
went down to austin and followed joe so
he's a [__] [__] because now i have
to go to austin every [__] month for
four [__] days to do a [__]
podcast um first of all i [__] love
austin i love to party that's funny i
couldn't live there though second of all
uh i could i could i could like if he
ended up you're going to leave your
house that i know if nobody kicked me
out i i'd just go down there oh if i
find my family i'll move down yeah yeah
i'm like
do you can i get your water in the sauna
what do you want me to do
so so but tom has no problem tom's like
leanne and maybe you're likely ann where
you know what you make you know what you
have and you go i can afford this this
will make me more money i'm not like
that i go i know what i have but i know
what i need so that if i lose everything
i can still stay alive that's where my
my brain's always on on like a flight
thing because i think it's from being a
broke comic and going
even when i was a broke comic i didn't
even know what i was making i was just
still living which is weird well because
you're the best in the biz like i was
talking about like uh ticket sales as
far as like the prices of ticket sales
like you pay attention to all that [__]
i like the business side of things yeah
but i still don't know like so we did we
did fully loaded was a festival i put on
for the summer
and i went to our first call and i said
uh i said
take every cent i'm earning and put it
back into the festival and they were
like
really and i and because this is how my
brain works i don't know i don't even
know how much money i was making i
didn't know anything about my my deal
points i knew what i was paying everyone
else and i knew i was going to make some
money but i go
the only way this festival's successful
is if there's
a ninth festival correct and if there's
the only way there's gonna be a ninth
festival is if there's a second one
correct yeah in order to have a second
one everyone that does this has to walk
away and go
bert knows how to take care of comics
yes i would do that again in a heartbeat
and that word spreads so that next year
when i hit up like ricky velez right
like someone someone i'm a big fan of uh
yeah uh
there's a bunch of names derek gaines
there's a bunch of comics that i'm big
fans of i know right but yeah keep going
but uh but no i just i just it's like
i've been finding people once i stayed
this festival i started watching younger
comics on instagram that i've never like
uh oh unfortunately
yeah great great comic great comic so i
go once i hit them up they go well you
know
you know shane gillis said he had a
[__] blast and i know shane mark
norman had a blast nicki glazer had a
blast joey diaz said he had a good time
yes you know joey diaz needs you to
really [__] step up the bar right he
ain't coming out so i can get every name
i want to do that or whatever i do so so
that's why my brain works with ticket
sales with numbers all that [__] but it
doesn't work that way with houses
yeah but you're the same as far as that
stuff goes as me and tom like because
i'm always down to invest in myself i'll
bet on myself i can't control anything
dane
joe i'll invest in myself you guys all
i'll put everything i have into this
yeah yeah that's smart in my business
i go birds a dying brand i would i would
say
he's going to be dead one day [__]
this is one of the biggest comics in the
world remember when we were talking
about um
indiana illinois like i live in a small
market whatever else and like the gene
in the bottle thing
this is something i got a text the other
day when one of my friends uh justin
realized that uh i was going out and i
was gonna be on the show and you're
gonna be here
and we live in the middle of nowhere
indiana 35 000 people right and he
texted me this and this is just to show
like your reach or the relevance or the
effect that you have on people that you
will most likely never meet ever in your
life and this kind of kicked me in the
nuts a little bit so i wanted to share
with you today are you talking about to
me yeah to you
talking about like the collective no no
no he wrote this to me
about you via text yeah via text he says
uh he says hey safe travels to l.a tell
bert to keep up the good work you could
tell in his last podcast with sagura his
face is thinned out his family's gonna
want him around
that's the number one thing like that
wait his face what his face is stand out
so like apparently whatever you're doing
the first thing i said what the [__]
like
people that you'll never ever meet have
this grasp and this connects with you
and you're like it's because you're so
relatable right i get a friend of mine
that call i call my fat friend wood
right he's six five 395 pounds
just a giant goon of a [__] and
i love the [__] but he's
probably gonna die soon you know but
like like if you and him are the exact
same person you guys are so relatable
and like everybody that sees you is your
best friend so like you leave such a
lasting impression on everybody that you
don't even have to meet them they just
have to see you being you and they're
like that's my [__] brother from from
seven years ago i haven't talked to when
i get to rekindle this friendship or
whatever like you're that person that
makes relationships and stuff like that
holy [__] and that's why i think you're
so successful because you have such an
incredibly relatable position
and you are vulnerable and you know what
else i think bert and your big fat
friend have in common i bet they're
smooth i bet they have smooth sacks and
this summer when you're playing in
summer sun make sure you scrape from the
pubes to the bump that's right saks
hummer boys yeah
it's a big boy summer but it's also
smooth sack summer with those big thick
sacks can i just talk to you about the
performance package 4.0 i wish you would
burp here's what i love about it i just
went to italy i'm not even joking and i
took my the lawnmower 4.0 it's got the
skin safe technology and it's got the
light so when you shave your balls over
a [__] over a toilet you can see what
you're doing yes and i shaved clean i
shaved clean for italy because i knew
we're gonna be walking around here's
what's great inside this you get this
the the trimmer you get the uh crop
reviver toner the performance pro boxers
which i wore all through italy and the
crop preserver ball deodorant so at the
end of a beautiful day with your wife in
italy and you want to hook up you don't
smell like donkey dough that dick's
right i'm telling you right now i didn't
mean to interrupt but but i please i i
sincerely sign up that it is the best
ball trimmer i've ever used in my life
what else she gonna use
there's nothing better than manscape and
get 20 off in free shipping if burt
didn't sell you on trim and you're nuts
all right to be like me and bert get
that smooth philly fade on your nut sack
get 20 free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
it's smooth sack summer boys get on
board or get left behind i need to get
those because i have a competitor and i
nicked my balls three times this last
time i was fussing them up and i was
like dude i'm never gonna do that [__]
again ever ever ever so i'm gonna order
that shoes yeah i don't know
thank you for doing the heavy lifting no
no
i i shave i've been a long time shave
bro hey mom won i i knew it hell yeah
yeah but sadly that means we're one of
those baby sorry loser i know i'm on one
i'm owen one here
oh
oh is that a
um
okay here we go hey something tell us is
this weird i so badly
like would love to make out with a ufc
chick after at the end of the fight when
there's no sweaty lips or swollen it's a
little alarming do you want that all day
that's a little like that i don't know
and by the way i only pulled that from
rob lowe insane elmo's fire after he
gets in the fight and he's like he
starts making out with chicks he's like
let's rock do you remember that have you
ever tasted blood i [__] respect that
have you ever tasted the light he's got
red wings he's got red wings for sure
that motherfucker's got i don't have i
ever tasted one like like like your own
blood oh yeah when i brush my teeth
that's also alarming right
it's awesome it's the thing so that's
good we should we should probably start
is everyone from britain yeah well it's
in london right so there's a lot of
british dudes dude this is what they do
over there
yeah like gypsies
yeah yeah yeah did you ever see the big
big john
big john mccarthy no no big john stud
this is like the early days of doing
rogue and i'm talking like what 12 years
ago we found a clip of he's like you're
a shite you ain't nothing but a shite
you come and fight me you'll fight me if
you will you know who i'm talking about
big gun
it was like that bare knuckle oh i know
what you thought it was like a
documentary
and he was the main guy right like oh do
you find my son come talk to him like i
you ain't nothing but [__] in the bucket
in the bucket i tell you by the way how
did i get that accident out so good that
was pretty and i made connor great like
a pirate you know it was before the
first time that's what it was yeah right
before he was a redneck pirate by the
way a little bit i've been sober five
days a little bit of booze kicked in and
it feels so good nothing better that i
can't go i like i actually thought to
myself i'm not gonna drink today knowing
leanne has a birthday party and then i
was like i'm drinking today it's gonna
be a blackout it's gonna be a smooth
section i was gonna put a lot of
pressure on that a lot of pressure i
would have been pissed if you guys are a
little too early to drink man i was like
what the [__] i tell you
i don't mind
can i tell you the greatest thing to do
the greatest thing to do with ufc this
is i want someone to clip this out and
then i want to credit for this
so conor mcgregor
right when he started to turn the corner
and like be who he is today
uh like after he knocked out aldo maybe
or eddie alvarez
probably got the double champion i want
to say it was
aldo
it was after aldo
and it was conor mcgregor there was a
guy who who sold a shirt that looked
like the i want to say it was derek
lewis it's not derek lewis i always [__]
people's names up here it was when it
was when they could still sell their own
shirts yes okay so um he was on that i
think he was on the same card so what we
did was we had a birthday party we all
had to go to and no one could watch ufc
so what we did and this was so because
of the party they couldn't watch it
because they were right and it was like
a chick's birthday party and so all the
dads i bought the fight on my
pay-per-view and i t-voted it or
dvd dvr'd it
and then
we promised we would not learn anything
about we stayed off our phones for the
whole party we went back to our houses
no one that's mission impossible dude we
went we went to bed we woke up at 6 00
a.m and showed up at my house and
watched ufc at 6 a.m on dvr drinking and
it was and nobody knew about it it was
the it was the the small
game
of all night long going you're not
watching it it's literally impossible
for me i try to do it if i'm like on
vacation or something like that or i'm
on the road and i can't you sometimes
can't see a big ufc it's i tell people
do not text with the results the only
person who gets is rogan if he's on and
i'll be like did you watch he's like
nope we don't talk he's good other than
that i'll get texting oh my god do you
see that whatever i legit connor knocked
him out i'm like god damn it dude yeah
i'm looking forward to it tomorrow you
ruined it yeah where fans are going
about it because fans will be at my show
if there's either be in the room and you
they're looking down their phone
oh yeah or or they'll come to me and
greet like dude conor [__] smoked
that dude like thank you [__] you've
ruined it yeah thanks a lot so who's
this fight these are two brits
david brown
doesn't look like you i might go for the
head tattoo guy i gotta see the other
guy head tattoos aggressive huh yeah
like
that's a tough go man he looks like he
has really good teeth that would be the
best thing to put on your
head guard so that the other guy saw it
and it kind of [__] with his head
like i have hep c
uh monkey
just monkey pucks and dots all over the
copies i was talking to my daughter
about monkey pox he was [__] monkey pox
you know they're throwing monkeys or
throwing babies off roofs
hold up hold on what is your group hey
what's your daughter watching monkeys
are throwing babies off roofs i don't
mind you can't coexist with monkeys man
they're crazy dude the monkeys in africa
yeah when you go you're like you go to
uh do like a safari or whatever and
you're laying in your thing before it
they just get in your [__] car and go
through your [__] as if they're human
gang of monkeys throwing babies off
roofs look at this
hold up they grabbed a baby out of a
[__] car
and just [__] chucked it out of there
what it's not gonna show up throwing the
baby right hold up is the baby in the
back of the [__] truck i think it
just showed him taking the baby out of
the truck and he just grabbed oh wait
there's no one no no no no look are you
[__] hitting me
and then they throw them oh they steal a
plastic bag from the truck oh wait
scroll down but monkey's throwing babies
off roofs
yeah i definitely don't want to see that
hold up a resident that his him and wife
were walking outside and their infant
son when a pack of monkeys only jumped
on their roof friday the club apparently
tried to shoe the monkeys away but were
unsuccessful you're not gonna apparently
ran to the stairs with his son but
accidentally dropped him which gave the
monkeys an opportunity to take him
before the parents could react the
monkeys picked up the infant and flung
him from the roof the child died on
impact well you've ruined my saturday
right burke yeah well done so [__] my
better ending
the baby laying on soft pillows and is
okay i'm just getting the remix of the
baby monkey box is all i'm saying you
[__] monkeys in general [__] monkeys for
real hey dude did you ever see that one
well there was this guy in india i'm
assuming he was sitting down he's like a
school teacher i know he's this monkey
that came around all the time so he's
like very familiar with it was being
nice to it and the monkey just said it
said [__] it and
she leaped leapt at him
bit his scalp yeah scalped him peeled it
back and then this dude was sitting
there like in shock and his whole wig
got peeled back they just got totally
scalped well you know the lady who was
like hooking up with the chimpanzee
giving him like xanax and red wine and
had him in a rope clearly [__] the
monkey street chimpanzee and then the
chimpanzee attacked her best friend dude
her best friend comes over and the
chimpanzee goes i don't like this [__]
how about this i'm gonna rip your face
off right i'm just gonna do this
ripped her face off ripped her hands off
the 911 call is insane bit her fingers
off bit her face off now did you see her
on like this one what kind of [__] are
you guys watching this is if i called my
daughter right now and i go hey isla do
you haven't know any monkey she goes you
mean the famous one
from 2009. it was a big deal and then
she came on like dr phil or maury and
she was like i'm actually doing okay my
face is fine it's like no oh you don't
have a mirror bubba right yeah like her
face is a knife i think it's better than
probably the option i think i think you
probably i'd go full red skull like
[__] just like that it's like that
guy in the wu tang clan who cut off her
face is fine
it's better than well well she just
looks like okay
i used to do your face right here by the
way these are heavyweights right here no
that's what she originally uh white
shorts can't be a heavyweight i mean
he's got to weigh 215 pounds 218 is
there anything to giving out too much
energy before the fight no big time hell
what remember there's a fighter that
does that brazilian
yeah i don't know if it was that you
know anthony joshua fights usyk today
too at 2 30. does he really did you know
tate fletcher got kicked off instagram
[Laughter]
did he really
wait so why did you know what captains
have to be pregnant and why why why did
they [__] kick andrew taylor to me
yeah because andrew tate gets kicked off
because
this is what's alarming is they're gonna
so instagram and facebook say oh we're
private companies but you're not uh
world [__] wide by millions and
millions of hundreds of millions of
people billions of people probably so
you're not a [__] private entity
there's no like that's what they claim
that's how they get away with most of
their [__] man so there goes ex boxer
influencer
um
andrew tape banned by instagram facebook
as tick tock investigating sexist
content
sexist content so who gets kicked off of
that
like if you can't be sexist but he's
also joking
but he's also joking too but his brand
is to make it sound like yeah his brand
is is that machismo kind of over the top
oh isn't it strange how popular he is
does that mean well some people take it
uh it's a lot of it's i'm i don't look i
i got nothing wrong with anyone
succeeding
in the social media game and i find
andrew tate pretty pretty interesting to
watch
it seems like he can legit fight and it
seems like him and his his dad was a
chess gang and him and his brother i
don't know if it's a a bit where it's
the same person and he's just not
shaving his hair
and i mean it's like he's a really
interesting study in in what is
happening but i will tell you his his
brand definitely connects with like 12
year old boys in a way
that no movie star ever has no
he's saying on you know on
kind of off the cuff like [__] do they
do tko's in bare knuckle yes i think
this is the tko
no he's at the end of the business
he stopped twice
the guy looks like a mini young
buckovich that's what he looks like but
if but if andrew tate has the lasting
power those 12 year olds will turn into
adults one day big time career here's my
thing when you ban people like this
especially for his model how you can buy
oh it's a victory it's a victory it
makes a mistake second he got banned i
guarantee you he went i just won correct
just won the game it's like with rogan
right when they were all going after him
right i wouldn't
i would i would beg to differ oh i
disagree with him
if you're talking about i don't know i'm
not going to get too in the weeds about
no please do i think there's stuff that
i think there's stuff that i don't know
i'm not going to talk about it i'm going
keep it oh come on bert nobody because
that's my here's my argument and i'll
keep it pretty loosey-goosey my thing is
when the media especially cnn once they
got involved and they were [__] on
rogan and they they were spreading it
you're talking about the the covet stuff
yeah okay not the n-word stuff yeah
that's the difference
i was like
no i think i think even joe would say i
wish that i wish that that hadn't
happened that's why i apologize yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i didn't have
an issue with no i agree with the covet
stuff code stuff i agree did that it did
make him bigger because what happens
what people don't realize is for the
mass majority they're not cheap dude so
let's i'm in middle america i'm in
[__] boise i'm in you know fort wayne
indiana i see these people i talk to
these people so it's like
you have a different perspective so what
happens is when cnn goes here's the bad
guy he's the face of the far right he's
also a trumper which he's not and they
create all these headlines well people
who don't know him go i gotta see what's
going on they listen to a show and go
holy [__] he's actually kind of in the
middle he's really interesting so his
view and i know he's wrong
i know you know for a fact his
viewership went up two million perhaps
so it went even higher yeah because most
people go who because he you know as
comics and podcasters we're in this kind
of we're kind of in this niche lane
and then once you go out and become
mainstream your people yeah people
aren't going to like him but a lot of
people are so it made him even [__]
bigger which he doesn't want no you know
it's funny because like the world you
guys show quiet on this you guys no no
no no no no no i don't
oh no no no i don't like it i agree with
you i agree with you on this stuff but
the other stuff like the n-word stuff i
i because they were coming after on that
i don't think that made him bigger i
don't think and i think even rogan would
i mean i
once again i don't like speaking for on
behalf of joe because it's it's a weird
thing because he is it's like speaking
on behalf of cnn yeah but uh but but
when that covets stuff came after him i
think more people are like well what's
that guy saying you know i think you're
right
but with andrew tate is very different
because andrew tate's doing a
a tad bit of a character he's a
character and so but joe's not a
character yeah we we know him he's
definitely the guy who's like you know
says some weird wild [__] and he means
it 100 about especially about health
yeah he doesn't like wild [__] like he
is the guy that's like no no no
intravenous uh intravenous uh stem cells
let's do it both of us and i'm like no
this is happening
you're like i'm getting energy to stem
cells my blood pressure's 160 over 110.
this can't be good yeah he's like we
need to do dmt right now like like right
now like i love that the media came
after him and i was like have you not
listened to his podcast
calling him on his 50th birthday i said
what are you doing he goes i'm in my
fifth round at dmt i'll call you back
and i'm like
okay different level
do you mean him in the sauna it's a i
don't know how hot it's insane it's it's
[__] finished sometimes we'll be next
to a [__] volcano might as well be
next to volcano so i'm in there and i
can tell he's like how do you feel he
keeps checking i'm like good and i'm
like oh this is a competition with him
yeah and eventually i was like i don't
give a [__] i'm out of here dude and
then he stayed in there ten more minutes
comes out because just because red i'm
like dude this can't be healthy for you
yeah he's like oh it's great for you
this is the same [__] that got a
polar plunge and could could barely get
through a minute
felt the pushback on the internet and
the next day changed his inner core
temperature by two degrees because he
stayed in for 20 minutes which no one
[__] does that's not even eskimos and
that's not healthy
but that's but my favorite thing in the
world and i wish i wish i i wish i
didn't love it but was when you tugged
the tiger's tail because i like there's
a small group of people tell me you
can't do something it's [__] up like
when we did we did sober october one
year and joe's pretty serious about
fitness
we did sober october and he did this
thing and he was like hey we're all
trying to keep our heart rates up or
whatever i don't remember it was but
he's like out with marshall and he's
like i'm on a jog sober october baby two
miles i'm out here with marshall and i i
just was doing a joke i was doing a
re-shoot of his video and i was doing it
with my dog i didn't even bring her
joe's video yeah and i go joe i saw your
video two miles [__] you for every two
you do i do four that's how i handle
things come on priscilla and i was like
where the [__] are you like i lost my
dog that was a joke joe did not see the
comedy in that and he went okay i do 20
miles and i was like oh my god what the
[__] and tom said i think it's best if
you do not tag joe in these videos
because i think then the next day he's
like he's in this thing he goes i broke
my [__]
my sprinklers are going off in my gym
that's how hard i [__] go and you're
like whoa holy [__] it is really we're
having fun man we fought we fought uh
who's the guy that's the sniper who's
tim kennedy tim kennedy
we go to greg jackson's thing for
[__] travel channel we train with
greg jackson uh uh uh and tim kennedy
and the guys trip flip so i take two
people on a thing of a lifetime
so i pull the guy in the corner he's my
he's like my traveler i found him on the
street i said i'm gonna take you on
triple lifetime let's go to new mexico
salsa
yeah and
greg jackson's yeah we're going to fight
tim kennedy right so he gets in the
thing and they're like you're just going
to spar with them and i pulled a guy
aside and said [__] that
i go take the tiger's tail see if you
can knock out tim kennedy
and the guy goes real i go dude he's not
going to be paying attention
he's totally watching over you he's
going through the motions
it's disrespectful yes me dude
so he takes a swing it gives him kennedy
and you watch
tim kennedy go to natural born killer
and he goes oh and i remember our guy
just went down on the ground and he's
like i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm good
yeah you know and there is something
different with those [__] dudes
is this fight already over
uh no i think uh they're not next no
they're the big boys are next
big boys they just fought no
heavyweights big boys i wanna fight i
wanna fight i'm going for the fat guy
talked about on two bears about fighting
uh
style maker stuff
but he's got a drink the same amount i
drink and then we fight
you still get [__] up but i like it
hold on
i get to say when we fight
oh so we sit in a cage and we just go
drink for drink we do a podcast we do a
podcast like eight rounds round seven
like i'm good
we just and you know i get i get to pick
how many rounds we drink and then
punches are grappling
punches are grappling like like on the
ground
i don't think i could roll i don't know
the guy's a [__]
kane can he kick
yeah let him
hey can i drop a little kick on you
today no
no no
we have to protect burn at all
you [__] up his wheel you [__] up his
wheels and you're back on the whole
danny who was it i was telling you last
week i was like i want to drop a little
kick on you who was that do you guys
remember it was like one of the last
shows oh eric griffin
yeah they're griffin
let me just locate the he'll never use
that leg again i like the guy on the
right
like the kind of dude that goes you know
what i'm turning my life around it looks
like tank
but he decided last night and they're
like what do you think of bare knuckles
he's like i'm in
man he looks like the guy that got
talked into it yeah he's like he's like
his buddies were like come on one more
shot and say yes yeah all right focus
i'm in now he's walking through smoke
and [__] bare knuckle you know dude i
wish the ufc had a little bit more
theatrical entrances that's where one
championship blows them out the window
yeah i wish at the end
i feel like that big dude starred in
lord of
can i tell you why my problem with the
hobbit is they couldn't name one dude
steve so i could follow the story i
don't know it's like everyone's got that
and they have huge
on yeah and you're like just get give
him a couple derricks and steve so i can
follow the [__] story and also their
giant feet make no sense either for how
tall they are by the way peter jackson's
a [__] gangster so we go to we go to
hobbiton to do do we're for trucks
it's oh it's it's in new zealand right
in new zealand it's other world it's
it's a dude's barn he flew over and
helicopter was like that's our [__]
location and they built it it's going to
be there forever it is a huge tourist
attraction we meet peter jackson we go
we're going to visit we have two comic
book fans
we say to peter jackson uh we'd like to
have you for an interview peter
jackson's built like that big dude who
walked out by the way yeah yeah and
barefoot always which i am i [__]
respect that respect oh wow i frown upon
that always oh i would judge him i'm
barefoot i'm always barefoot yeah i'm
always i got flushed i know you're cool
when i met you i got i got you i busted
my balls out being the flip-flops all
the time you know what i do i can't do
it i pulled against your move the other
day i was going into a nice restaurant
they're like we can't let you in with
flip-flops and i went what if it's your
own [__] brand of flip-flop and they
weren't brand they were like yeah yeah
yeah and they were like okay you're good
free waters yeah
they sell out we put them up for sale
can i please tell you how much i can
sell out you want a pair yes what size
i'm a fifteen
[Laughter]
i can't tell you how much i appreciate
that story what if it's your own brand i
pulled up the lady you got a big dick i
get it right i think she saw my name on
the flip-flops like oh i know who you
are yeah yeah
but uh
you but you paint your toenails too yeah
yeah yeah yeah
honestly that dude
he looks like he's from iceland and he's
a batman no bro he might win he looks
like he looks like the enforcer if he
knows angels
why did the fat guy sign up for that he
shaved his back last week
like yeah yeah yeah i'm going for that
guy they did not steroid test him i'm
not that guy i'm kind of jacked yeah now
it's how do you not root for the big boy
though during this like y'all work for
the dog
actually he's not even that big of a dog
it's a negative 155 to plus 180 so it's
really not that big for peter jackson on
bare-knuckle fighting right now listen i
mean you know that boy can take a punch
so peter jackson says i will not
be on your show
but if bert chrysler wants to podcast
with me i'll do that that's [__] dope
and that's what that's a dude tapped
into the [__] thing and so then
he we put a mic on him to to do the
podcast and then okay
yeah he deserves this well he's mad
by the way i'm going for harris oh oh
anybody who's not going for a hairs get
out of that one
can you find out who follows us on
instagram before we pick our guy
did you ever do that you ever look at
him
you're like oh [__] it looks like i'm
[__] going through your rifle try
having to pick just trying to have the
pick fights when they when they're your
buddies fun oh that's the worst i
wouldn't do that that's so stressful
nightmare man yeah i like the big the
big fella sloppy but i i gotta go with
the killer look he's got a he's
currently he's 44 and harris is 29.
here's your 29 i mean
do you guys build like armadillos 29 i
don't know what you're thinking of
you might have flipped it it might be
body fat there's some dyno going on
there
29 is high but it's still high i'm 25.
you're doing great i'm i'm right now i'm
246. my buddy
i'll tell you my workout today uh i saw
your video you posted yeah what i'm
saying
running
uh right i'm going surfing in hawaii in
two weeks and so
i haven't done it since i've been big
because i can't get up as well since
you've been making did you gain weight
or have you always been a bigger holy
[__] that is enormous too
why did they set him up with this fight
it looks like it looks like lee syeth
versus rogan no it looks like lisa
versus tate fletcher that's what it
looks like
look at this oh wait so wait a minute so
the the andrew ted guy or whatever his
name is like fletcher
is that right no it's take something
tape flex
no no no not him the other guy andrew
andrews so that guy oh
shut up i thought that the andrew tate
guy was would get banned because he's
doing a pyramid scheme on that like as
far as like he had like a hustler
university or something like he was
he has like man university or some [__]
i love it oh have you have you seen that
documentary on netflix the ma matai
taiyo one the notre dame
have you seen it uh i've never loved a
villain more in the first five seconds
transgender i immediately i went my
heart breaks for you for the transgender
yeah you're out of your [__] mind my
heart breaks oh i i i've never met a
villain i hated more no she ruined his
life bro she did ruin his [__] life
ruined his career you watch that at the
last 10 minutes spoiler in three two one
you watch that
at the end he they're like well you know
how are you feeling now he's like listen
man this is the the the documentary okay
uh you're talking with a man
at the end he's like you know so many
people who were in the stands who had
the the hawaiian leia's and all that
stuff he's like and they cheered for me
he was the same people they make fun of
me now he's like the same people take
pictures with me and then make fun of me
on instagram he's like and then the
memes started making fun of me with
pretend girlfriends and he's like it
ruined my life
and you're like to me i watched that and
i felt for him so much fell for
manchester united also because
i'm the guy so [__] dead spin [__] dead
spin who this piece of [__] reporter
goes i mean quote i i mean we're not
going to get all the facts of the story
but we don't like people
yeah yeah of the big fight
it looks like he's at the end of a
[__] buffet line and he's like he's
like i can do one more round but i'm
going to be sick tonight it's going to
be a tough go man
i i didn't i haven't watched the whole
thing that spins a piece of [__] when
desmond showed up i actually turned it
off because i went what's that that
energy kind of like broke my heart that
you would try to destroy but i didn't
know what catfishing was at the time
neither did he he was like the first one
yeah i had never heard of captains like
2006 oh dude i got catfished hardest
[__] college for real i've never i
don't think i've ever told a [__] that's
before
it was in colorado oh really yeah
uh transgender uh oh for sure oh dude
it's oh for real for real for real like
it was so bad like i i i had to be like
dude you guys are gonna love this story
like because it was so hard well let's
hear it like shut some dick or what
all right so do me a favor ends with him
sucking pull up
hey real quick this wasn't a fight at
all huh no no no real mismatch we were
rooting for the rudy of the the bare
knuckle here and it's just not for him
but they turned this into an eating
contest i still picked my guy if if if
your muscles mcgee over there i had to
get hype overbeating [__] tub of goo
over there like come on man he's like
that's a sweet guy you gotta be like
yeah all they're both they're boys
all right keep going with your i wanna
hear your catfishing story storm ireland
pull that one up storm ireland what is
that oh yeah it's a person uh yeah did
it come up it just it shows storms in
ireland okay
earthquake california i'll send you hey
hey matt hey hey hold on before we go
here hey before we go here yeah that was
four miles that was in a red flag
thailand that one's it that's it right
there
that's it
so i wish they could see this so
i got
is that i can't believe i tell the story
all right so listen so i'm i i just
david goggins i just played wisconsin
right yeah university of wisconsin just
played there and i had a good game this
is my junior year in college uh i made
my senior year so i think it was my
senior year so i just had a good game
and they did like um so you know like in
college like if you do well the next
major game on like abc or whatever it is
highlighting the yeah they'll highlight
you come in the interview you do
whatever else right because they're
expecting another big game yeah so our
next big game happened to be ohio state
so um so i had a good game i didn't
everything was normal but i did this
thing and it was like two weeks later
and then i have another good game at
ohio state um i guess a guy named
charles bentley i had a good game
against someone ever stunned yeah so
anyways so i come home from that game
and i have a voice message on my
answering machine and this is in like
98 99 something like that and i come in
and it's just in college at the same
time and i'm five years older than you
well you're also the machine um so um so
i get i get a voice message and it's
like a falsetto and it's like hey this
is storming whatever else and it's like
hey i need you to do me a favor and give
me a call uh this is my phone number so
i would say don't call it right but i
don't think it's anything strange
because we had a girl that went to high
school with [__] dope ass chick and
she had epilepsy and i think her voice
was kind of like a falsetto because of
epilepsy or whatever else it was i don't
know but she had a really high high
pitched voice right from the autism
that's like i [__] one episode
never mind keep going so
uh i go to practice everybody was like a
saturday sunday we go to practice right
monday i come back home and there's
another voice message because i deleted
the first one and it's like hey i really
need to call me somebody's using your id
uh your your identity and they're doing
in touch with me and this is who i am is
what you need to reach out to all right
bet so i call this number and then when
that when i call them up it's uh an
answering machine answering service and
the guy's like it's like it sounds like
it's a building a large commercial
building and i'm like hey i'm looking
for storm ireland he's like jew he's
like do you know who that is i said no
he's like well that's kathy ireland's
baby sister she's up on the 30th okay
for the record in the story i am
committed
so then i go i'm like well a [__] gap
patch me up so they pass me to her room
or to the photo shoot that she's doing
up there and she's like uh and and and
somebody answered the phone like i'm
calling for storm whatever else
you level yeah and all the same like
because we're like photo shoots yeah
and there's a guy in
yeah that's a hundred percent so then
she's like she's like she gets on the
phone oh that's who you are oh right on
i'm so glad you called back everybody
take ten i have to have this
conversation so i'm like all right this
is this has got to be real you know and
it's like it's like 98.99 like there's
no real internet right like it's still
kind of a newish thing you know and neve
didn't do the catfish documentary yeah
this is for sure this is new new you're
going to tell me your mate so
so and then she's like hey you know blah
and i'm like listen if i'm talking to
[__] all right so anyway so the story
is let's start real quick his name is
manti teo it's not matteo patel it's a
comic
book so
so she so she tells stuff right so storm
tells me that she has a fan that's
reaching out to her on on her web page
and he's giving his physical description
but used my name and then that she was
walking by in a photo shoot the other
day and heard my name so she turned
around and looked and realized that my
body wasn't who this little dude was
describing it was like five seven one
fifty i realized i'm a totally different
animal already alarming but okay so so
that was the position was that a photo
shoot that's what happened right so then
so she's like that's why i want you get
a hold of you because somebody's using
your id whatever else okay it's a nice
lady just a nice lady right so i'm like
well i'm kicking it to kathy island's
sister i'm gonna start kicking game to
her yeah so i start kicking some game
tour whatever else we said maybe a dick
pic no no there's there's no camera
phones back in the day okay yeah so
though so i was it was just conversation
that was it so i talked to her about two
or three days she's like do me a favor
we're starting to talk a little bit more
do me a favor don't tell anybody because
i'm an up-and-coming model you might get
into the nfl let's not let paparazzi
start swarming you like they do me
because who my sister is this makes so
much sense to me oh yeah
uh just a couple of my teammates that
i'm really good friends with right and
then i tell my one of my best friends
cause my roommate john guydos i tell
good times i'm like good he's an
attorney now hold on is this when drew
brees yes yes do you tell drew brees
about storm [__]
and some breeze is a christian oh by the
way so right now he's going he's going
hey man listen you're going to find love
let it brother breathe keep going drew
was a [__] great time in college a
[__] great time especially who's
younger yeah dude he was so dope he was
so he came home
came home with me to springfield a
handful of times when he found jesus
dude he was [__] yeah i don't want to be
the same good time dude he was so much
fun like
[__] was fun well anyways so all
this stuff's going on i tell i tell good
this makes a friend you have a friend
named drew brees her name's storm
ireland oh my god it's a weather pattern
happening in your heart keep going i
love it so then so when i tell him so
i'm like hey i tell good times dude you
won't believe this whatever else he's
like he's like man that sounds nuts so
then i go home that night and he calls
me up he's like dude are you what are
you doing i'm like well i'm in my room
whatever i'll say i'm jackie
i need you to sit down and i'm like why
he's like storm island is a 38 year old
black man with multiple person out of
disorders and there's one in six
different countries it's not real like
you've been duped and i was like i was
like no [__] way dude no [__] way
so he pulls up and i'm like i'm like
listen it can't be true so he's like
listen
i'll still [__] her i'll snap i'll still
throw some
wait till you hear the parameter of how
deep this thing goes it is bananas so um
so i'm like so uh so he's like listen
have her write something on her web page
this is really her she has a webpage
like storm island.com or something she
writes something on there about hey matt
it's great to talk to you uh you know
about your dogs whatever something
that's david guys dude so check this out
evil villain david goggins so uh i tell
my lawyer right i'm like hey man just
let you know this thing came up he does
it could does a cease and desist
whatever else the next [__] day
on my door i'm like
what the [__] it is david goggins what
the [__] can be happening right now i
open the door and and and it's a box
sitting like almost like seven it's like
a box sitting in front of my door and
i'm like holy [__] what's in the box
what's in the box so so good times comes
over and we open the box up and it's a
it's it's literally like all this like
propaganda like modeling stuff of that
[__] there with pancake batter
that picture pancake batter all over his
face superimposed on kathy island's body
and it's a handwritten note please
believe me this is who i am blah blah
blah you won't be listening this and
this and i was like dude there's no
[__] way right like i think i'm by
the time i'm completely sold that this
is a
a training crazy shit's going on
so then i leave and go get ready for nfl
combine right this is where it gets
[__] up so the whole thing so i tell
the team i'm like dude you guys got to
listen to this because it's so [__]
hysterical right i got played to the
left and this is what happened whatever
else so
then i go out to denver to get ready for
the combine with lauren so i go out meet
lauren i go out there and it's it's like
a communal house so i walk in there and
there's already six seven dudes from the
state of colorado or wherever else and
they're up in there and they're all in
the living room because i'm taking a
dude's place so as i'm coming in i go up
the stairs this dude's walking out and i
walk up to the living room he walks down
right because there are elevated places
or whatever
so as he's walking out one of the dudes
on a stair on a chair was like hey tell
storm we said goodbye and i was like
storm you mean like storm ireland and
they were like what the [__] how do you
know about storm ireland you don't see
everybody dude
dude smashed dude smashed and then like
but like it was in a car and and just
threw it in her butt and said that she
said that that she liked it in her butt
instead so yeah that guy's gay though
yeah
that's a gay man like so that was part
of the story and i was like dude you
want to support me
and sometimes i see myself in that
scenario dude keep going i
they told me this entire story about how
like the dude was a virgin didn't know
any better he was awkward as o-linemen
he's uncomfortable around chicks and he
didn't know any better and he smashed in
a car and that's what happened and so
they told me this whole story once all
this stuff happened and i was like dude
i cannot believe this is real and i
can't believe the iceman
lives in colorado
no hold on we're just breathing past
that the big old lineman [__] the dude
took his virginity dude
to a dude
dude
i'd rather have given it to a dude than
the chick i gave it to
because i was that bad i would rather a
dude have my secret than a woman tell
everyone what i did i was listening to
beyonce
awful
oh i bet i beat it keep going
i bet i beat him so bad that you go oh
i'm so sorry i told my story go ahead so
go ahead hey i might have saved you here
i might come get you here cheers guys
hey i love you and this is the time that
our kids are like dad why the [__] do
you tell that story on air
we talked about this earlier like he's
like do you ever have like things that
you wish you could put the toothpaste
back in the tube and not share about
your family i go i talked about their
periods on conan yeah
they were in like eighth grade you
talked about their parents on your
special am i special you had your mind
all right okay let's hear your periods
or your uh
my period story all right
so there was a girl she will remain
nameless because but i'm drunk so i
might say her name later on accident i
mean first name's fine so um she lived
in her neighborhood madonna and i didn't
know
i didn't know
like like i didn't know where we grew up
was kind of was was poor
but i knew what we had was a normal life
we went to down to this girl's house who
had a brother um
and they had instead of having like a
box ring and a mattress they had a bunch
of mattresses all stacked up and that's
what they slept on and they had a bunch
of different mattresses in a couple
different rooms and we played this game
i was
no like uh so i'm in fourth grade so i'm
nine years old okay okay okay okay okay
so okay very important fact of the story
not sure i can beat this one yeah that
sounds a lot like molestation but keep
going
i'm just wrapping my head around matt
keep going all right so they were
playing this porno called don't come
knocking when the trailers rocking and i
remember because i saw and i was like i
was like the nervous excitement of like
oh my god what am i watching please
google it that is what my brain was
going i want to watch this tonight
for sure um and then like there's there
was another one called inside pamela
wells and i was like i remember like
those guys i think i can't i can't i've
never seen anything like that before yes
i was consumed by it and then
so we ended up playing this game where
like whoever had the stick had to walk
out with her eyes closed and obviously
you'd be like cheating and looking
around she's not trying to [__] dudes
yeah but you also feel like
and her brother was playing the game too
keep going
that's where things get weird
hey man hey real quick dude
so the the chase storm story right right
right transgender right that's a dude
and then uh fourth grade another dude
appears right
well no hold on no there was there were
four of us
two two children two dudes no no
three dudes
and
the girl okay and then girls related to
two of the dudes one of them one of the
dudes there's no
yeah
that's what it was before the internet
things were different yeah
virginia during a gang bang
like so it was a really and what's weird
is like that went on for like a summer
and so the weird part is like when i
would come home i'm a kid right i'm nine
years old i don't know [__] so like i'm
supposed to be out riding my bike and
and like and throwing rocks at windows
right and i would come home and i'd be
so nervous i'd be like my knees would be
knocking and stuff like that like so
what'd you do today um and i wouldn't
know how to respond yeah like it was
weird but like so that's my virginity
story it was like that scenario is my
virginity wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait what
i think she was late fourteen hey man
and i'm sure there had to be some stuff
going on in the smallest station oh yeah
well yeah
hey hold on so you would play this you
you left out the part where you had sex
so you would play the stick game yeah
and at some point she was like hey you
have a flash stick
right so like you would you would like
squint through your eyes and you'd
wobble through and you'd touch her with
a stick and then you'd go lay down on
the mattresses the sack of mattresses
and she jump on and she'd ride you right
and that's
right so i'm so i'm laying on my back
and she's riding me but i'm so young i
can't not at the time i can have an
orgasm but i'm not producing sperm oh my
god those are the things or semen or
whatever right don't mess around back to
those days
and like it's
but it was like it was a really
interesting time because like she would
tell me like i didn't have an orgasm so
i'm still a virgin so this doesn't count
for me yeah she's so she's like i took
your virginity but i'm still a virgin
yeah she's a [__] yeah well or she's
molested and she's a survivor yeah trump
yeah
i'm glad you didn't say her name
yeah now you're saying
this speaking of blood this guy is not
doing it they took his virginity on his
face jesus christ did your story beat
that uh i don't want to tell my name
so i was nine no i'm kidding oh
holy [__] what is wrong with you guys i
knew i knew your family i uh i was 17 i
was old
but i just me normal
i i tried to say that to my [__] kids
the other day 17 is the normal age
and what they say uh
i don't know i'm doing i hope they're
like no dad 23 is normal i don't you
don't want to burn [__] it's on
podcasting no there's times oh
i'm assuming only because of the
pandemic did they penalize them are both
virgins i'm assuming only because the
kids these days are very very backwards
we were talking about my wife's taking
george up to orientation at college and
there was a girl in front of you was in
college
so what the [__] and uh don't say where
i said yeah so um
she
the girl in front of her they gave her a
key to her dorm room and the girl said
what's this for
she said it's a key she goes for what
she goes for getting in your room she
goes
oh
will they be locked
and she's i'd say you can't come to the
school right but kids these kids have
been in they've been in quarantine for
[__] so it's totally foreign
like there's so much they don't know
they don't know about lines they don't
know there's like my daughter's one time
my we were at the hard rock and
i'll be back there september 34th no
atlantic city thanks for asking and uh
we my wife my mom called for the next
room on the landline and i gave it to
georgia georgia talked to her and they
handed me the phone and goes what do i
do with this and i was like oh i was
like you hang it up she goes up and put
her on the bed and i went
what the [__]
they've never they've never used a
landline in their life i'll tell where
i'm using a landline i'm glad you
brought it up bert uh chicago next
friday den theater one show only august
26 yeah theater one show one night only
in chicago next week and then after that
i am in appleton wisconsin i love that
hey
appleton's is september 8th through the
10th and then ontario california ontario
improv september 15th through the 17th i
close out the summer in boston boston uh
laugh boston september 29th
i was like goddamn it your memory is
great you don't have cte yeah what the
[__] i could do that without that
hand there i'll tell you what would help
that go with the backhand dude if he's
using kratom he would not be bleeding as
much listen i use kratom to fire my
brain for a podcast stand up it's my
limitless bill bert it's the best
focused product i've ever used best part
it's all natural i take happy hippo
before i do stand up or whatever i'm
doing so my ct doesn't flare up kratom
is like what cbd used to be and that's
why we trust happy hippo because the
wild west out there in the kratom game
visit happy hippo herbals.com use promo
code thickboy for 20 off for life use
that code as many times you want that's
happyhippo herbals.com use promo code
thickboy for 20 for life back to the
program
i respect it so i i didn't know that
backhands were not legal by the way um
triller is trying to buy bare knuckle
like the place that put on that last one
i did that uh trailer triad yeah they're
trying to abide i thought trailer was
kind of triller and dizone are a little
bit of legal troubles i thought right i
wouldn't be surprised can i tell you i
think jake logan logan logan logan logan
paul should
uh stay away from boxing and go straight
to wwe well that's what he's doing he's
so good so good well dude he's so good
at that and by the way i don't i mean
look no disrespect but boxing there's no
long game in boxing uh-huh no not at all
and obviously he doesn't need to do it
but it's a lot of money it's a lot of
money very quickly i mean that's what it
is yeah it's a lot of money for him are
they really i don't mean this but you
find like floyd mayweather like mike
tyson yeah but for him that makes sense
but his brother what jake's doing is
different jake's trying to get
validation from the fight
community which is very tough and he's
fighting like legit dudes like they're
on two different paths logan's doing the
biggest most famous guy possible most
money possible older jake's trying to
fight real dudes like nate diaz what's
up what's the age difference uh
i think three or four years well also
like he's not he's 35 40 pounds heavier
than whoever he is
like
right like no
like he's a 210 guy 20207 guy no no no
one i've ever done
180 no 190. there's no way he's probably
190.
he like he could fake nate diaz at 170.
that's gonna happen that's happening
well shoot i mean why not it's two two
biggest names in the game right now i
love that the ufc went hey real quick uh
before you leave nate here's hamzad oh
you want to leave you're gonna walk
through this chechnyan via [__]
sweden fire to leave this [__] wait
what i don't know what's happening so
nate diaz has been asking for a release
from the uc for hey he's been asking her
a fight b he's like let me get out of my
contract and you'll see what we'll find
your fight don't worry you want to leave
you guys yeah i want to leave and fight
[__] jake paul and even dana goes
it'd be best if he just leaves fights uh
jake paul so nate's like yeah let me
[__] go no that'll be a great video
and they're like you have one fight left
though bubba we can't let you go without
your one fight everyone's like oh it's
probably gonna be the connor trilogy or
whatever and then dana goes no no we're
doing hamzat who is terrifying the most
terrifying guy in the welterweight
division so you got to fight this up and
coming young lion who's from dagest
chechnya via sweden before to get out
when you know when you know he's like a
minus 900 it's like there can be a worse
matchup for it really when you and you
know that nate's not hungry anymore like
it's the worst part like you can't be in
that game for that long and still be
hungry just doesn't work man yeah i
think i think that's the same for
everything
oh everything comedy everything you know
what
did dave all right so as a layman i
don't know [__] about comedy right
except for being [__] awesome but
like do you
did dave show he's a minus 12.50 goddamn
that has to be
dude
did did did dave chappelle
decide to come back
because
of the political environment that we're
in and he's like [__] it i have the
biggest dick i can swing it and decided
to do that
or was it the fact that he just wanted
to come back and also you said his name
earlier shane gillis that dude breaches
some [__] awesome
awesome and he covers so much have you
discovered tim dillon yet
i don't know oh baba
also like the political and like rants
yeah tim dillon
bill's got a new special on netflix
and i'm going to say this very candidly
maybe the best episode of podcasting
that rogan's ever done shut up tim
dillon's on fire top to bottom and gives
a 12-minute rant that i listened to with
kyla
about the death of america and it was so
awesome and it was just it's tim dillon
is i i look i i've known
tim for a while so i'm you know
obviously and i know shane i know all
these guys i'm not a bad i don't speak
battle on anyone so and so i always
speak good and so sometimes that means
that no one believes when i glow on
people but i will say this
wholeheartedly
every time tim dillon talks i am fully
engaged and giggling
and he's the best podcaster doing it
he's probably the choice
as far as entertainment i need to start
listening to hold on
podcast tim dillon is the most
entertaining we have by far by far uh
and
i'll say this shane gillis who brought
up shane gillis yeah uh
easily easily
by the way easily one of my favorite
hangs in the world like just to be
around him you would love him he's like
when we did fully loaded i brought he he
came out and did fully load i think he
did the whole run with us and he was
coming for me he went before me every
show
and you want to talk about [__]
thunder yeah i mean it was like thank
god i have ripping my shirt off as an
opener because i i was i legit we're
talking about 12 000 people in in a
[__] twelve thousand dude there was a
time we it was did you know huge venue
becoming a machine was gonna be no the
[__] machine i had no insight of
branding of marketing yeah i was a guy
that was taking his shirt off because i
was drunk at comedy clubs and it was and
i thought it was fun and i also didn't
like having to think about what shirt to
wear and i did it one time and it worked
and then and then i thought wow one day
i'll just put my shirt on and do a
special and i'll murder because i can do
it without doing my
shirt my stick and then and then all of
a sudden i realize i can't perform
without a sh with a shirt i'm sweating
i'd feel uncomfortable then you became
ellen you know ellen has to dance every
she's like
yeah that's he came allen has to rip his
[__] shirt off but i like it i like
performing shirtless i love it and by
the way nikki glazer performs shirtless
uh during uh uh fully loaded did you
really know wrong
and looked like
wow
she looked amazing yeah
my wife was there and and was
and walked off and was like that was
[__] awesome that's so so when you
perform shirtless you are so free
because there's nothing there's no vote
it's all i don't know man there's
nothing
she gave it all away
you gave it all away
you know i do it right but that's your
thing yeah but no but like oh dude you
got to try it i'm like in the middle
though there's nothing you have to worry
about
at night at the improv or at the store
and do it in the main room and
everyone's got a performance i would
only do it if it was with you [__] i
wouldn't do it anywhere else i can
understand that i understand that
because i i wouldn't also your thing
yeah i mean it definitely is it
definitely is now definitely my thing
yeah i don't think i ever planned on
being shirtless at 50. yeah i don't that
wasn't in especially in front of so many
people yeah like you know what's funny i
say this all the time and
that knows you
you know hey by the way that's why are
you at the point now because so i played
in the nfl before right yeah my nfl
pictures are long gone you can't find
them it's all fighting and whatever else
yeah are you at that point now where
your fighting pictures are gone and it's
almost all comedy probably yeah at this
point no that can't be right because
buying a fellow
hold on i got to see one yeah google
bring a job no no no for you i want to
see you yeah
and if that and if that's accurate then
what we should do is have the fans
upload a bunch of modeling pictures of
matt for nfl so it just comes up i
played in the [__] nfl put it matt
mitchell uh nfl of course it's going to
pop up
just regular
this regular if you type in matt
football right it comes up right let's
make football
well of course football's going to pop
up
yeah well it's up there but if you don't
type in you [__] yeah dude
how much did you weigh when you're
playing football look at this one
look like peter jackson was 275 here
that's a long hair right there
is that for the vikings is that for the
vikings
hey matt was robert smith on the team
then what were you there with randy moss
and the boys or what
i was there with chad carr no i wasn't
uh chris carter no i wasn't who's the
quarterback do you say chris pepper
pepper dante culpepper it was a year he
hurt his knee
yeah was the coach
tyson was there when i was there i
bombed him i bombed in front of the
vikings harder than i've ever bombed in
front of anyone in my entire [__]
life
were you doing were you doing it in
front of the team
in front of the team and the boosters
about 3 000 people it was rough
corporate gig for the vikings jim
florentine bobby kelly in a corporate
game bobby kelly's a monster we all suck
dick on stage
it was so bad it was so bad that the
only person i met was the kicker uh
old school dude the kicker for the
vikings back then was like a guy's been
talking to the k
klush or something no no no he's he's
the king he's like the he's like the one
of the biggest kickers one of the
biggest even all those pictures are
going too like
all my my vikings picture i mean my
giant's picture and my 49ers picture
they were taking with the camera
i mean that's like you can see the haze
yeah i was going to show you some really
bad haircut photos um
that uh
when i was 315 my face was so fat that
it looked like somebody suck a an
inflation needle in my face and blew it
up
i've been there
i guess i gained so much weight dude i
got to start my phone didn't recognize
my face hey check this out
i don't know you saw that picture with
university of michigan right so we
played university of michigan on the
facebook issues going on a guy named
anthony thomas they call him the a train
right so we're playing football at
michigan and it's kind of missy rainy
hazy day right yeah so i get through i
hit uh a tree in the backfield i cause a
fumble i'm on i have a hold of a train
so i'm on the back side of the fumble my
my defensive end aiken adele jumps on uh
jumps on the fumble and one of their
offensive tackles jumps on the ball so
aiken and the tackle are fighting for
the ball i'm on the back side of the
deal of the offensive tackle right so
aiken and the dude are fighting for it
facing each other and then i'm on the
backside pretty much big spooning the
tackle sure the offensive tackle yeah
and i'm like yo you got it you got it
and he's like no i don't and the big guy
was like i got it and i knew it wasn't
aiken's voice
so i'm in there and i'm in the bottom of
the i'll call aiken right now and i'll
verify this story so i'm like uh so i'm
like all right okay wait wait and i take
my fingers and i stuff them in the
dude's ass right the the old the
michigan guy stuff him in his ass and he
freaks out oh my god let's go let's go
with the fumble we get it and aiken's
like dude you are [__] up he's a guy
he's like the guy was like he's hitting
my ass he's screaming on the bottom of
it yeah so then we so aiken the whole
pile gets up and naked's laughing and he
gives me the ball he's like that's yours
[__] like you earned that one
real quick are you chase storm
for sure
we find out you're the only captain
this guy could legit fight
oh you'd have to do that face down yeah
if you can face
if you have a face tattoo from
apocalypto you better be able to [__]
fight
so i'm coming off the side i'm coming
off the field on to the sidelines we
just got recovered a fumble right we're
getting smoked get some chocolate on
your fingers maybe so i'm over there and
with aiken we're rotting off and we're
kind of laughing we're giggling about it
right my oh my d-line coach gary emanuel
is standing with his arms crossed on the
sideline and he doesn't say [__] and
he's just shaking his head like this i'm
like what man we just got a fumble we
should be happy right now he doesn't say
a [__] word he just points to the
jumbotron and it just happened just
happened to have enough space where you
can see me taking my fingers and jamming
it and do that and the cold crowds like
boo and throwing pennies
little airline liquor bubbles f-word
back then
was it in michigan and purdue at
michigan a lot of times dude it was
great
oh dude i was so proud of myself like it
was great i'm surprised the coaches gave
a [__] they got yeah this guy's suit's
terrible yeah hey there's one bruce
buffer buddy
uh you got to give the guy a you know
you gotta like that's like me taking my
shirt off though you'd like to come on
dude there's one christian what are you
doing let's see if my wife's seen let's
see if my wife's seen her oh [__] i
can't see anything without glasses
really
you and rogan can't see [__] without
glasses huh yeah
they say it happens because your dick's
so big all the blood goes to the click
[Laughter]
a text from someone
and you're like hey can you come to the
there was a dude that'd go to the
hospital oh never mind i shouldn't say
that
[Applause]
by the way with the stories i've shared
today i'm pretty sure i'm gonna have a
lot of chats
that's how you make a career in
podcasting yes
vulnerability right around you yes
everyone's going to behave everybody's a
victim right step on top of god early
days of rogan i just would just go down
and burn bridges i hadn't crossed me too
man my family hated me oh i'll get texts
my mom's son says [__] you i'll i'll see
like a comic these days and be like hey
man and they'd be like hey a big fan i'm
like oh cool you don't listen to
podcasts yeah it's like okay no you
don't talk [__] about people though i i
used to i stopped oh did you really yeah
yeah i've never done that i used to
aggressively and we're talking about
like a year ago like on two bears two
bears i would get onto a rant about
something and just tom has this like
cocaine energy of like do another one do
another one and you just and i would
talk about because he likes it and i
would just talk [__] about people i
didn't even know comics
not comics i wouldn't do comics as much
i'd do celebrities oh see that's
different if it's like a will smith's
thing like it's so big i'll i'll have
fun with that i definitely did about
will smith yeah of course don't ask for
it then bail out now big fella
is the middleweight what's middleweight
85 is this uh boxing or mma weight class
that's 185. i don't know
that's
175 175.175 to look like he must be five
foot three yeah they've got to be well
we got to go for the guy in the lime
green and purple right because he's from
america
yes how do you know
because uh underneath his bio said
america
i [__] respect that oh he's yeah yeah
bring it i love that energy yeah united
states
yeah and the other guys from united
kingdom oh
oh oh yeah yeah he's bringing it hey if
you're going to ask for it you better
come get it now dude bare knuckle
imagine anxiety would you do cam knuckle
matt never my wife just texted me there
was little literally this [__] is gnarly
you will never that's it
shout out to your wife who's watching a
bare knuckle match at noon well she's
watching this right
she was like she
so i'd send her a picture of me drinking
she's like i already toasted you about a
minute ago i saw it on tv because uh um
mark we had a little something to post
it yeah she's like i saw your drinking
so i decided to go in too she's like so
if you're drinking i'm drinking let's go
by the way shout out to new wives huh
yeah i got a [__] 52 year old waiting
for me
[__]
have you seen those black guys
[Laughter]
another year babe
yeah i'm really excited about having sex
with you a whole lot more
she is she cooking stuff no she uh
shut that down
[__] face tuned her baby
brought that [__] in i [__]
cleaned it up
give her a bigger tip
no her kids are [__] massive right
now
[__] bird [__] did she call you
what she call you she uh the machine
they call me bertrude mostly i [__]
love it they they're no one's ever
called me dad really
your kids call you like nerds uh georgia
call me dad but that like everyone's got
nicknames we're a big nickname family
and that's leanne me too like george's
george is george for me she's grug to
isla um grug grug and baby i or i or and
leanne um
liam's a boss she uh you call her the
boss no she no i i i
have three girls you have three
daughters two daughters and then uh and
and
yeah she's i'm she's gonna be pissed
because i don't understand money
sometimes so like i bought this dance
floor for like
three thousand dollars yeah
and i bought the president and we were a
bad good president
really good president and uh she's not
listening do you want to tell us what it
is did she ask for this president no she
didn't want a president all right but i
was like i can't not get her present and
my sister was like don't worry i have a
contact it's one of those stores you got
to get a appointment to go get the thing
no the jewelry and so i i go to the get
the appointment i buy the one thing and
then i'll say it's good seriously i was
like we need to get her two things
and so i bought her two things and she's
gonna get the price on this
this [__] impromptu birthday party
and be like pissed
she's gonna ruin her birthday no i don't
think so i hope not we can find out
we can call it a way to fly um is this
way to find out you want to see how piss
she is yeah let's see it
i'm excited about this me too yeah let's
see
what's up boss i told isla i saw that i
said the way to fix it
hey how are you doing
here she's on our backyard there is a
dance party in our backyard
you are the best
that's all i needed to hear
thank you baby we thought you were going
to be mad it's going to be a lot of fun
it's gonna be a lot of fun did you think
i was gonna be mad well have you seen it
have you seen your present
no okay it's a friday
we'll just wait the dance floor is no
present
oh that's i know that's how your brain
worked by the way i got i got my so i
got a present for you the girl's got two
presents for you and uh and then talk to
sandy about who's coming and pete and
then and i'll be home i know that my
channel is coming i'm super excited
about it yup michelle's coming and so uh
so diplo yeah and so by the way so tate
fletcher the um
so she's all here
yeah
he's the one dude
i don't want to spoil all the surprise
but do you know who's playing music
yeah all right so i'll be home in a
little while uh everything should be all
set up pete's in charge everything i
love you i'll see you happy birthday all
right love you too thank you baby
she wasn't mad at all no she wasn't at
all you didn't even tell her she was on
on on radio so she could have been like
[__] laid into somebody oh she should
have said that if she was like yeah she
is that word or what if she was like
bert last night was a disaster
you kept calling me [__]
storm i don't know what the hell is
going on what's up little dick
oh well look who it is two-pump jump
here they stopped that fight
i guess it wasn't getting lit up i guess
i understand do you think stop getting
i'll ask you guys is a fight stoppage a
lot like a snow day
like you're you're happy where you're
like you're like oh [__] yeah i didn't
know i was i didn't know i was winning
yeah yeah yeah i had my last fight when
they stopped it in my head i'm thinking
thank god
my opinion thank god yeah but
yeah yeah yeah that lets you know where
my mentality's at
yeah i remember my last night dean's
travis brown when they stopped it in my
head i'm like dear god thank you but i
pretended i was mad
yeah what are you doing i got backstage
like thank you i should because i'm like
thank you you you know i have so much
other [__] to do you know what the best
thing is possible is when i kicked i was
fighting his dude in canton off he's a
russian dude and i kicked him in his
nuts and 13 seconds into the fight and
they and he couldn't fight anymore so he
can't fight so i got a full paycheck
because i got paid a flat fee not a show
in a win so i got paid a full check for
nothing didn't even get touched no
damage kick them straight in the nuts it
was over dude and i was like that's like
a snow day
[__] yeah our last day of fully loaded
right there that's why it's not rained
out
chin's on top and they were like and
everyone in the buffs with everyone and
they're like we're still getting paid
right i was like yeah we're still
getting paid i didn't realize i was
producing the festival
and so then we get back on the phone
they're like so we can't have another
one of these rain outs and i was like
really and they're like oh that cost us
dot dot dot and i was like wait all of
us and they're like oh yeah you're not
getting paid you got to pay everyone
else yeah but you're not getting paid i
was like i'm not doing that again yeah
no more rain days that's tough yeah it's
time yeah right now uh rains rain snow
or sleet buddy we're going
all right the the u.s boy won jake
boskwit
does your brain go somewhere else when
you work out
what do you mean i don't know
today do you listen to music no i i
don't listen i
do cheat codes in my head i think my ocd
kicks in so today today i was yeah so
i look at things as
in in in sets of okay well we got to do
the first one
and then the second one is halfway there
almost the third one we're almost done
in the fourth one yeah like i do these
cheat codes and i was wondering if
everyone does that or if people enjoy
the actual feeling of a muscle flexing
um
like like i just i mean does anyone like
well arnold used to say that he felt
like he was he was orgasming like i'm
coming like yeah like the pump gave him
the orgasmic feel so he was like he
loved the individual reps yeah when i
used to train uh in arizona with a guy
named chattikay um
he would do we would do like sets of
the going down is the eccentric that's
the yielding right so the yielding is
the eccentric the going up or the
overcoming is the concentric so it was a
five second eccentric
go up for a quarter hold it for two back
down all the way back up down for a
quarter and back up so all together it
was about a 12 second rep all included
right and you had to do you had to do
six sets of the 12 second rep
so that was miserable it was a lot of
[__] work and i would take myself
literally every single rep that i knew i
had to do as soon as i would unwrap it i
would go through the best [__] i ever
had the bet and i would go through from
the moment i met her to the time i
finished is that 14 year old
and it was it was running through my
brain so that's i would remember the
memory and then i would have somebody
else touching me along the way so i'd
know when i was done uh but i would take
you almost like close your eyes and go
through i would go somewhere else and
think of a happy memory and you're doing
squats with a giant erection yeah for
sure and it was weird because that would
take a lot of viagra back then a lot
that helps you yeah it helps you the
blood flow uh-huh
it's actually illegal to take during
sports it's a performance enhancer
your blood flow yeah oh that's because
it moves it around
interesting
the uh yeah i don't i i enjoy lifting
weights more than i i used to love
running like running was my thing for a
long time that's my thing now i [__]
broke my you're a big dude to wrestle i
mean to run yeah well i wasn't always
this how well i i got hurt i got hurt
three times once significantly i re i
tore all my uh triceps or i tore my
tendons in my tricep doing a movie and
so then i and then
the recent movie yeah the machine you
know his own motion picture coming out
yeah as soon as this whole ukrainian
russia thing cleans itself up
yeah yeah yeah we're kind of in a
holding position
and oh my god yeah because
because
the machine store in russia because
you're killing ukraine i was planning on
a premiere in moscow and
i fighting down that card coming out
ripping his shirt off
let me fight let me fight fedor in the
opening you know who's in our movie
who's that uh
um uh [__] brittany grenon no uh
ufc champion uh ufc number six
uh
um white guy russian russian dude he's a
russian dude now
he was dming me when i was fighting
fatal he's like dude say these things no
kerr town off he's like say these things
and i was like dude
i can't do it
this
this guy
is
one of the funnest hangs is he really
ever been around no way one of the
coolest dudes
i meet him i meet him and he uh we're
watching a soccer game at a at a hotel
in russia in no in in serbia and he's uh
and he's
having like cold beers but you know like
like really enjoying these like uh
slides uh
try like sure like gym shorts casual
like real real casual but it's still in
really great shape he's in great shape
and he's having beers and he goes uh hey
i i know your buddy huh and i was like
yeah and he goes uh rogan and i was like
oh yeah and then i realized oh [__] i
don't i didn't realize what i was
talking to i knew we hadn't realized
that i was like oh [__] i watched you
fight so immediately he goes call him
and i was like done [__] facetime
rogan i'm like rogan and he's like holy
[__] and like they [__] go off that's
cool and then we every time he showed up
on set that guy was the funnest dude
that's so dope but like but like and
he's an amazing actor really
like
dude like the smallest things that you'd
go in in a movie where you'd go
i don't want to spoil too much but the
smallest things he would make him like
like
it would make it his own he's so [__]
good dude
that's heartbreaking that that the
russia ukraine war is delaying that yeah
that that bums me the [__] out but
that's how i've i tore all my tendons
and i had to get surgery let me get a
zipper on it let me see that thing
oh yeah
no not too bad i mean you had a
horseshoe before that did you i mean you
know i put a little kicker back there
yeah i know and so i got i i don't even
know what that means the uh but but that
made me gain i got to 265. i was 240
shooting the movie the whole time i
could run at 240 run four miles a month
what are you healthy at
i mean i don't think i've been there
since high school i think i think
probably two
i would say 220. right now you are 246.
okay i've seen you look i've been the
best i've looked in i was 265 for a i
and when you when i go on tour i party
pretty hard and uh we [__] yeah yeah so
270s you're kind of your big your big
boy i've never been 270. i've never been
270 yeah you just didn't weight yourself
you did probably yeah yeah it probably
happened what's the biggest you've been
three what's wait wait you're my dad
you're my dad because i go to i've never
been 265 and i watch my dad just roll
his eyes and he thinks the thing you
said but didn't say it
no you have you just didn't wait that
was the day you're like i'm definitely
not getting on the scale you were 275.
you've been 310 315. that's what one i
wanted you guys to see that picture when
i played when when i got to when i
played
arena ball yeah when i got there i was
that big yeah and they were like we need
to get to 285
and so i was at olive garden just eating
eating and i'm like what the [__] am i
doing yeah and i left great
this
oh and i knew i didn't want to play
arena ball because i was talking like
the star of the team and he's like man
hopefully practice ends man i get some
packages and i was like oh yeah package
come in the house he's like no no no i
have to deliver them like what we're not
i worked for ups doing like you're the
captain of the team you work for ups
he's like oh yeah i only make like 35
grand a year i'm like check please i
literally got my [__] volkswagen tour
ag and drove straight back to colorado i
got to figure something out the day i
played arena arena ball
i was on the tv show yeah i i i [__]
love your life los angeles a lot it's
kind of i'm a great funeral uh the i
will have a grave you know i would i
created or married i'm cremated or
buried uh let's not i don't want to go
too deep in them is it cool if i sell
merch at your funeral can i tell you i
want to sell tickets to it i want to do
i want to do i want to stream it live
well you want to talk i'm looking i'm
looking to build a great i kind of want
to be there i i'm looking to be i want
i'm looking at a great set i'm no sugar
is going to talk i'm going to [__]
make sure rogan talks and i'm like the
walk out with 250 for the greek if you
sell it out we got a door we got a
better door deal than you would maybe
250 they feel bad for you so you can get
a better door deal that you can here's
the thing bert let's fake your death so
you can see it we do the night before we
do anyway what a [__] pub stunt god
that'd be amazing
dude let's catfish the greek why doesn't
someone who's been canceled
why don't they fake their death yeah and
just [__] and
you fake your death well no he's not
coming though so it doesn't really do
much benefit to him he's still going to
get weird will they leave him alone i
have a weird thing about the army hammer
thing me too i i don't i don't want to
get too into it because what is going on
with you today
because because
sometimes i
you say [__] you don't know the facts i
don't know anything you're podcasting
that dude i my entire life is bro listen
this isn't all i have like a real
election
[__]
the black chick that was a republican
candace owns canada's own this isn't joe
rogan can assange you can go baby
it's like it's like it's weird they're
not coming here being like okay all i
know all i know about his thing is that
he was dming people fantasy [__] this we
have the same take brother dude he i
went for a fist bump sorry dude so he
never physically consumed a human being
and now here's my thing here's my thing
bert right crazy fantasy whatever never
ate anybody went to cannibal rehab
where the [__]
is there cannibal how do you know we
went to cannibal rehab because he went
to costa rica for the rehab this is the
one place you know
they have the first of all
other issues i'm sure like i don't know
if he's interested in cocaine and heroin
rehab yeah and they just and somebody
just tagged it cannibals i would love to
go to rehab i would love to go like a
nice light rehab where they serve
marijuana and white wine and you can
just and it's just a little subtle and
like hardcore workout today eating clean
and then at night they put like you have
a table of like six right you don't know
each other a therapist that table four
bottles of white wine couple joints and
they're like and this is all you get for
the night so like enjoy it wean your way
down it's like a retreat dude i talked
to you
like jerry garcia i talked to you all
the time he's been to like legit rehabs
i think for 30 years i tell phil all the
time like dude let me come with you he's
like he doesn't really work like that
i'm like i'm gonna have it i'm gonna
addicted coffee nicotine whiskey and
he's like not awesome i'm like let me
just come and check it out i never got
to party with theo when he was uh when
he was partying like i only heard the
stories of him partying wild boy which
bums me out because he makes me giggle
he makes me giggle
can i and i know he's going to be angry
if i say this i believe i was the first
generation of people that discovered how
funny he was i believe me and amy
schumer chris fairbanks uh mo mandel
donnell rollins red grant we were the
first generation of people
that realized how funny he actually was
he is
and
just as a manner as funny as people
think he is on a podcast he's better in
real life
like him would leave here after king's
scene go to earwax and sitting down it's
like bro i've never met him never spoken
to him you would love him he is you'd
love him and he's a very sweet guy
he's supposed to be here for real
all in the show today yeah um i've heard
that he is um
if you don't know him he's standoffish
and kind of awkward because he's very
guarded or he's just so he was raised
he's just so awkward his dad was when he
was like around he didn't know me he'd
be like 120 his dad was like 90 years
old when he had him so he knows yeah
yeah
and then he got what you got emancipated
from his parents when he's like 14. yeah
is that what they got so my wife now i
had a vasectomy i'm 44 my wife now wants
to have a baby and i'm like listen man
mike my baby's [__] 11 and a half
almost 12. like how old's your wife
though it all depends 33.
well she's fine but yeah but i already
had a vasectomy though she felt like
versed well
thanks a lot burt i appreciate that
she's watching right now yeah i mean
let's just put the camera on me very
simple surgery get it reverse and then
you can have a family yeah with him and
then you're and then you get to share
all the joy you have with his first
family you get to share with him again
and you're not too old it's the best i
would love to be an older dad are you
[__] kidding me i want to start again
so bad my wife didn't have a period in
europe and she goes what if i'm pregnant
and i went
then you'll be here for another 20 years
yes because like because you're [__]
[__]
tired oh my god i locked it up your baby
dude little bird junior you can't
[__] give me a boy give me a boy
that's what i've been training
give us a champion
give us a chance i think about it often
off champion you know how good you'd be
good in this one yeah you've already had
three tries right yeah you've learned i
i have two tries i learned how to [__]
that one up you know i get worried
you're in the same marriage i get
worried i had three kids i had three
kids and then i have a new one i figured
they'd be like what the [__] we weren't
enough i get worried about that no
they'll take care of them done they're
dead
they're going to college they're going
to live their own lives they're going to
babysit you you're living in the past
yeah yeah they'll also help out with the
kid yeah i can't wait i would love for
liam well i was really got excited when
californian
110. she was the excited she was going
to
by the way i'm busting balls i know that
i do this a lot on two bears if you all
understand i love lyanna i love my wife
but [__] whatever yeah yeah she's
older than i am and i i wish i hadn't
signed up for that game
she's always like i'm getting so old i'm
like you are shut the [__] up about it
i'm still young as [__] how are you
deciding i'm like in my 30s
no i turned 50 in november so
let me ask this question here just for
anybody that's ignorant as i am
big boy's coming up again by the way
florida state was voted the hardest
partying school in the country yes when
he was there then then they went through
and said okay who's the hardest partier
here and that's how you you became you
van wilder dan wilder roughly roughly
that's what it is
uh the broad stroke if you get into the
details
rolling stone wanted to do an article
about florida state because they were
the number one party animal or a party
school
and they asked for it this is charlie
ward years yeah yeah you got to see that
guy with so many yeah i'm 37. i've never
felt more confident about any human
being is that work done years also work
done work done and i sat next week
directly next to each other at
graduation at graduation we sat next to
each other he goes you're the party guy
i go you're the running back and he was
like yeah he was going to tampa and i
said hey man just you know i have
buddies in tampa if you need a hookup go
fishing or whatever and he looked at me
and he was like i don't think i want to
hang out with your friends
yeah i got [__] today let me tell you
this much um when he played for atlanta
right for like the last couple of years
uh work done yeah yeah so he's a great
deal so i i was getting off a block and
i reached out to try to tackle him and i
thought that little [__] broke my arm
he ran so hard he hit the hole so hard i
couldn't believe it like tough [__]
dude charlie ward uh played [__] bats
won the highs on the played basketball
for the knicks yeah for like like
forever career
here's what here's what [__] him by
the way charles oakley i heard he's a
[__] real-life gangster really you
ever see him trying to kick him out of
the [__] oh would not have it dude
he's so would not have
um secret time there was a situation
where i might have gotten kicked out
it's a hardcore secret time
i was the situation where i got kicked
out of madison square garden is that a
moment i was gonna get kicked out and uh
why were they kicking out you know
no no no no
that could [__] up business were you
performing are we just there i was there
okay and uh they were like dot if dot
dot dot happens
it will be a charles oakley situation
and everyone around me is like make it
happen
i'm with them
it's good
to sell tickets off this birthday this
is [__] that's awesome i'm not that
guy like i'm not i am that guy a little
bit that's why i'm excited to see what's
the name fight because i am that guy
where i can go no one's on my team
anymore but like i got to be pretty hold
on by the way who is this you're talking
about it you said it twice i don't know
mike perry mike
or mvp
i don't know mike perry mike perry mike
pegg pine the mike the guy who was in
the ufc the guy who's in bellator
black guy white guy white guy white guy
like michael perry he's playing tonight
yeah yeah oh i [__] love playing
right tonight
there's there's a video of him on tmz of
him getting kicked out of a restaurant
oh yeah and he got [__] up yeah
his quote he goes man my hands are uh
bisexual he's like women can get it man
can you get it you're like holy [__] i
love that dude
i was on the same card with him at uh
for triller he's ripping andrew tate
promos
should take a second and watch some of
him
and then also mike perry also did the 21
of me found out he was pointing one
black and went i can say the n word yeah
legally completely
by the way he says it so casually in
that video there's a few videos where
you say the n-word and people that's not
the thing people notice yeah they're
like no it's you beating up the old man
by the way
by the way he doesn't look like a bare
knuckle fighter to me he looks like he
looks like a guy he's doing sculling or
what's that where you slide the uh
curling curling yeah he looks like an
accountant to me
i've never talked to my kids again i
have to start doing curling uh listen if
you haven't heard already smooth sack
summer baby when you're playing in the
summer sun make sure your escaped from
the pubes to the bum that's right this
summer to keep your balls cool while
still looking hot like burt kreicher you
got to do with manscape the leader and
below the belt grooming is making sure
we have all ball this summer by giving
our pants partners everything they need
to stay fresh dive head first in the
smooth sacks summer dive head first okay
well by going to manscape.com for 20 off
and free shipping with the code cfc the
manscape performance package 4.0 we've
told you guys comes with the lawnmower
4.0 trimmer with the light on it you can
do it in the shower in the dark so
nobody knows you're doing it all right
you got the freaking uh what else you
got the weed whacker the weed whacker
for your ears nose hair it really helps
who has nose here for uh i'll tell you a
guy we know is the biggest podcast in
the world keep going yeah
you ever getting close to rogan's ears
and you're like why don't you use a weed
whack
how did you not get cast in the next
lord of the rings uh manscaped even
threw in two free gifts for the
performance package 4.0 the manscape
boxes and shed travel bag so you can put
it all in there man get torn off and
free shipping with the code cfc
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with the code cfc manscape.com
it's smoothsack summer boys get on board
or get left behind who's this white
walker
this is who julius caesar was afraid of
this is who the roman emperor empire was
afraid of these are the gauls and the
germans that's what they looked like and
they were scary this is what hitler
wanted for everybody
hey can i tell you something real quick
yeah too much i just gotta just save me
from a great hitler joke thank god keep
going
um keep going man i i just got a texas
said [__] glover check sarah is in
lafayette indiana right now what and
he's like hey man he wants to hang out
well i'm not there obviously but like
glover
he used to be the world champion light
heavyweight yeah and then he lights up
dude like i mean he was he was checking
he was chuck liddell's understudy right
now um and like they were like when this
is who came in was supposed to be the
man yeah but it's weird i just got a
text like yeah why would he be in
lafayette yeah i met chuck liddell and
chuck be cooler for this storm what who
are the two guys chuckling ellen chuck
liddell and tito ortiz nope chuck
liddell and uh chuck randy couture
so i meet chuck liddell at a spike tv
event i'm at the bar he comes up i'm not
i don't know if he ordered a drink or i
don't know but he came up next to me
and i'm at the bar
and i turn around and i go oh [__]
champ what's up you're the best man big
fan you know because i've been i'm a fan
of ufc i'm not like a study of it but
i'm enough that i've watched a ton of it
i go big fan man [__] and you go said
something i said you always be the champ
i fist bump them and then i go over i
think they're standing i'm i mean i
don't know if it was dana white but
there i go over
and
it's
randy couture and a bunch of people and
as i see randy go to her i was like i'll
just say the same [__] i was like what's
up champ chuck lindell walks up as i go
what's up champ and jungle dell just
looks at me like so we're all champions
wow
y'all you always be champ to me he's
like yeah
[__] i would love to take a minute with
randy kotor's ears
just to look at him hey dude oh just to
really get into it so i'm i met him in
indianapolis he was dating a chick there
um and i got a phone call he was down
there i went down to bed and it's before
i ever met him before and he's like hey
i'm in town for a couple of days let's
go grapple tomorrow all right bet sounds
great this is i'm going to one up this
is it maybe
this is maybe 11 or 12. and he kicked
the [__] out of me
out he [__] me up for probably an hour
and 12 minutes and beat my ass so bad on
the ground grappling wrestling like
there was nothing i could do to get away
from him in any which way possible he
[__] like he's so strong and when i
got done dude like his pummeling you
know what pummeling is
so like when you're wrestling
and you're like you're like changing
under hooks left right right yeah um
like swimming he's so good at that that
like i had no option so like it was like
constantly fighting for my life and just
simple actions and then he would like
pick me up launch me drop me on the
ground and then just molest me however
he wanted to really like and he was so
good at it when i got done he's like he
got up and goes
whatever you've been doing up to this
point you've been wasting your time
figure it out and literally put his
clothes on walked out of the room like
seriously oh dude dude he beat my ass
you remember when we fought leota
machida yeah so i was in toronto the ufc
flew me out to do appearances i'm in the
hotel and i'm i don't know i'm going to
hang out with a chick or something i'm
like man i'm chilling i'm literally have
reservations at one of the nice
steakhouse i'm walking out in my nice
gear and rayne
couture's coach uh i forget his name
jiu-jitsu coach goes well
who i was training with you and you
train with him and he goes where are you
going like uh dinner and he's like no no
we need you man randy owns a gym here uh
extreme contours in toronto he fights
tomorrow we need you i'm like what do
you mean he's like he needs a
like a sparring partner i'm like bro
he's like just come on i'm like all
right get my [__] we go on this hummer
giant hummer it's me ranting toward all
his boys we get their pulp this gym
nobody's there they open the gym and he
does this is the night before the fight
he does ten five minute rounds at the
hardest you've ever seen so be a guy
admits going with him and then i would
jump in and no rest like no rest at all
work work ten rounds yeah he's and we're
fighting dude yeah so then they go all
right dude we want you to hold mitts and
move like machida i'm like
lyoto machida the [__] karate guy oh
yeah i'm not even south paulie you'll
just stand south ball first one okay so
i'm holding the mitts like leo machia i
felt so lame i'm sitting there he misses
the [__] mitt [__] right oh my
holy [__] takes me down molly watson
beats jeremy yeah we're sitting there uh
after all i'm like i can't believe train
is hard before i fight you that's how
you got it that you want to be champ you
gotta do this i'm like yeah i should
probably incorporate some of this man he
goes you should because i'm glad you
came in i feel like tomorrow's gonna be
special like no doubt
goes into the doctor i'm cage side i'm
like here we go i help them train i'm
telling them i helped them with this
he's ready to go
bro 30 seconds of fight front kick
yeah for real yeah he's walking out
locked and see him look at me go
and just keep going oh my god hey dude
he
they said that
they said that i think it was actually i
think it ruined his career they said
that
though he does ten
five he does five five-minute rounds
before he goes out to fight five rounds
savage like he gets better the longer
the rounds the deeper the rounds are
like like for me like we sleep we sleep
and we don't do [__] until it's like 15
minutes and we stretch a little bit
maybe hit a couple of pads kid a couple
of dummies so other people can hear it
and then we leave yeah that's it this
[__] works
randy couture have children yes here's
my question his son thought yeah no okay
so here's my question and i mean this is
this
uh uh ryan right brian couture
here here's the question
so we were talking earlier about
toothpaste back in the tube right and
kind of dads we are and i said there's a
lot i regret i regret uh uh i regret
uh the i we were i was saying i i look
at lawyer dads and i go i envy them
because they just her dads who show home
they're like hey did everyone have a
good day
how was practice and their schedule is
predictable their schedule is
predictable and they're predictable
they don't like have stories of like oh
you got blackout drunk and said that the
us government created covid you know
like and they're like oh yeah okay you
know like
what would you rather have a dad like me
who's a tad bit embarrassing and shares
all your secrets on stage and and maybe
or or and i says or like a
randy couture as a dad where it's a
little bit more like randy couture's i'm
sure he probably had a
[__] bar up here where he's like son
you you perform here like a military dad
you know like like because i but i think
if you had boys there'd be pressure on
the boys too to get to a certain level
like you're setting the bar pretty high
for your kids too like my kids my kids i
feel like i'm in a unique position for
this because i played in nfl yeah and i
fought yeah both my kids play football
and they wrestle yeah uh so i feel like
i'm in a position so what kind of what
kind of dad are you do you get like do
you get
do you get into i couldn't watch
george's softball because i'd have to
take a vape pen to the outfield because
i would get so intensely competitive
i have none of my own athletic
accomplishments in the house
nothing like there's nothing that you're
not coming to my podcast studio yeah
yeah it is
trust me it looks like bert passed away
if you walk into my house
you would not contribute if you break
into my house you'd have no idea you
broke into my house no clue whatsoever
but i do that because i don't want to
put pressure on them
like i don't want to put pressure on
them and i feel bad about that and now
jacob's playing d-line so like that
means
yeah so that makes it even worse he was
it was outside linebacker until
yesterday you don't give him any tips
hey let me let me [__] up with some
truth right quick
i was such a fanboy for you today for
real that i'm not [__] with you i'm
being for you that yesterday was my
son's first varsity start
and i left the game early to fly here so
i could be here today
like that's a [__] hey listen that means
a lot thank you like i left the game by
the way it's my wife's birthday and i'm
here with you
after the first quarter
after the first quarter i was like you
know
i was like jacob i hope you understand
he's like dad i get it he's like he's a
machine
he's like so he's like i get it how did
he play um so he he played he played it
was his first time playing d-line
but i got texts from friends of mine
that were for the opposing team yeah i
know like dude tell your kid to stop
[__] everything up he's like we can't
get a play off right now yeah like and i
like i still i sent it to him was like i
don't know what you did but whatever you
did you did it right he's uh he's 16
almost 17. oh [__] yeah so like so was
his first he was a junior year and it
was his first fight
um
yeah but he's smaller uh he's
maybe 5 11 now he's probably 170-ish
uh he wrestles but like so the point is
is like i played the nfl here and i and
i fought so he does the things that i
did and but i don't want him to feel
pressure on it because out he's not me
and i don't want him to be me i put all
the press and then and then the coach
the wrestling coach who's also the foot
one of the football coaches was talking
to one day and he's like hey man do you
do you feel pressure because of who your
dad was or whatever else and he kind of
almost got teared up i hope you don't
get embarrassed jacob i love you but um
and also get better right like [__]
figured out but also like hey yeah also
saying to my daughters you're going to
get recognized when you go to [__]
college yeah deal with it i'm cool as
[__] be cool
sorry i'm [__] don't tell your
friends to buy [__] merch
who the [__] i am yeah so is matt jesus
christ
i want them to date a guy like jacob
who's like your dad's cool [__] let's
hang out what the [__] like hey you know
what's weird i said my kids school in
thick boy you say with a promo code on
the back of the shirt you know what's
weird is that our your daughters
will have to have somebody that has a
mindset of a killer because you are a
killer like like like like the way you
push your brand and the way you are
nobody with an average personality will
ever do yeah they're gonna get together
they will trounce on any dude that's a
normal dude because you can't handle
something because they grew up with you
no they can't be boring yeah oh there's
no [__] way hey this guy looks like
conor mcgregor if it didn't work out for
him
gregory was a dj
he's so well called yeah done yeah he's
like conor mcgregor you sold molly he's
got to be living in a homeless tent in
l.a he's got to be oh he's got beautiful
eyes but he's a diamond beautiful eyes
what i was going to say the white guy
with dreads you know he's built a family
of animals because that's all they know
yeah like and because like you've done
always and you've always been successful
so like they're like their impression of
death you marry your father [__]
you marry your dad there's gonna be a
whole lot of conversations
did your daughters uh because when you
you weren't like bawling when when they
first were born right no no but now
they're in the house you're living it's
like you know you're crushing it now so
but they're they're used to that level
you know what i'm saying no they're
they're uh actually they said this
doesn't sound weird i don't hope it
doesn't sound
isolating but
they said one day they were like i'm
really glad that we were poor
because they go i think we know what
it's like to have money but we also know
what it's like to be poor that's
everything and and my wife's family is
very modest you know that's an
understatement and so i'll beat you
there a bit i
i bet i i bet you don't have to go to
mexico back mexicans from mexico no no
across the board illegally okay you want
to play maybe you've got me
got me dirt
my daughters are are grateful like i'll
give you a prayer example uh this is
when i've had too much to drink i would
never share the story i love you before
i talked about losing my vagina
key lime's got a great uh like key
lime's out of key west and it's key lime
pie is my favorite pie i love it i love
it
it's a good key lime pie but you know
what there's no in between it's either
fantastic or straight straight [__]
trash i could take
key lime pie is like [__] do you have i
will try it any time however don't take
a fat man's advice on it
i disagree do you have a favorite key
lime pie uh oh i've had a lot of key
lime pies well is there one though dave
williamson shipped me one i don't know
where it is but he shipped me one from
williams and dave williamson's uh opener
for me he's a comedian he's a big
barbecue guy he's like d barbecue
i'm a barbecue guy by the way for real
his opener is like the bbq guys yeah
that's [__] i'm tied into that whole
championship touring world oh okay
yeah please yeah and so
he sends me he sent me a key lime pie
for my birthday that was one of the best
out of key west but i loved i loved it
was probably that place that's a that's
a place that makes my pieces might be
nellie and joe's i think that means i
get this i get this and i've been doing
it so i was telling rogan my recovery
with tequila is through the roof
so on my whoop i'm getting like 88
percent recovery on every night where if
it's improving if i drink vodka my
recovery is for [__] like 34 because how
does it how does it monitor that
so my whoop uh i don't [__] with those
anymore oh did you hear about the dude
who's [__] dying ass chick was a
reporter for uh espn
and they were like they always they wear
fitbits and they compare their workouts
and statistics okay and she saw when she
was working and traveling dude was
[__] some chick at like two o'clock
in the morning for like an inconsistent
period yeah his heart rate went up yeah
and so that's how he got caught stepping
out on her when she was out working a
million times and the chick was a
[__] killer yeah well no matter how
hard wait what was the story you're not
supposed to tell them before i actually
no
[__] yeah i'm sorry i killed it no it's
me i definitely because about this the
[__] key lime thing i have no idea
no we'll talk about it later we'll
figure it out the uh unknown is that a
pelican's hat from new orleans i have no
idea
you're a straight bill guy you know what
i wore this you're not a trucker hat guy
no i can't i have a big head here put my
hat on see how big my head is
enormously well we're going to but
mine's already bigger i'm telling you
mine's bigger
oh wow i have a big head yeah i don't
know actually this hat fits me yeah
here throw mine on him put this on it's
not going to fit and that's bigfoot you
guys don't want if i have uh any kind of
scabies or something oh i i look like
hey
yours is yomka i look like bobby bigwig
you know who you look like no you look
like a grateful dead fan yeah [__] yeah
i am dude i've been telling you i just
love the grapefruit i thought i told
them psychedelics [__] love the
grateful death really that's great
pumpkin music you look like punk ass if
you're tucker
their songs too long though right no i'm
a jam band guy
yeah their songs are too long and also
jay garcia right great ice cream great
ice cream the band's better with john
mayer that's your cherry garden
hold on well but that's his ice cream
but that's his eyes it's not it's his
ice cream it's not it's no it's it's
based off of him yeah but yeah
you're grateful
amazing they're better with john mayer
though yeah they're no no they're not
better with johnny oh they're not bigger
they're not the mayor hey their song is
too long though right no no when you're
sober when you're saying you gotta
[__] rock sunday you wake up early
make yourself a coffee put on the dead
get into a nice big-bodied sedan
a a big-bodied sedan go on the grateful
dead roll the i don't know whatever i
got whatever i got and you roll it yeah
hold on the window good stereo system
just full sound i'm listening to the
grateful dead i'm not drinking and
driving today but i'm just i'm gonna
hopefully get into a car and let's see
the grateful dead uh so so i've been to
i don't know probably 14 15 dead shows
i had tickets to the last jerry show in
chicago and i couldn't go because i had
football and so i had to give the
tickets away and so but i've been to i
was the last dead shows in in chicago uh
fairly well i've been uh how do you
don't have the first time my wife the
first time my wife dropped that
expensive and eight shrooms was the same
day in austin texas at a dead show for
real our guy our guy in philly suplex
suplex uh haslam
and it was like he was like they're
ridiculously expensive oh no what size
do you have
13. 13 in sb dunks 13 and everything
nike
i wear 13. no yes can i give you a ton
of [__] shoes that i do not [__]
wear that i never put on i'll tell you
what you give me though well let me look
at them right but i buy i buy
dope shoes that i will never wear
but i can get convinced into them me too
and they'll be like you'll like these
and then i just wear it i'll tell you
what i'll trade you a pair of uh
grateful deads and 13 for all my shoes
yup deal all right um
what color it is oh there's all my
sunglasses uh 12 and a half 13. so let
me buy some of those so my son can get
somebody why don't you just send your
son a bunch of shoes
so i'm going to what i'm going to do is
we're going to
exchange emails yes and i'm going to
loop in my wife
and my wife will send a bunch of shoes
to your son because i have a ton of
shoes that i got i got it really into
especially over the quarantine buying
shoes yeah you have some dope kids and
but there's only a couple i wear i only
have like you're letting me know
whatever you want for them my kid will
be [__] over there no i'm so excited
i need more shoes like you need an std
i'll [__] give you the grateful deads
and then you send his kid shoes hey wait
how about widespread panic how do you
feel about [__] love hey so airplane
i'm a huge widespread guy airplane's one
of my favorites
guys might as well be talking about
chinese remember when you and jess
barnett were talking about engines [__]
off you can hold on too true
my buddy this is going to get a little
sullen but my buddy kills himself right
we're both boy spray painting fans and i
and i had this i'm in clearwater i find
out we're in alabama my wife's family i
find out i'm a mess the last thing i'm
doing i'm in my pool and i'm listening
to my phone
and it's the last message he sends me
and he's he's [__] hammer but it's
not it's not it's not the day of it's
you know how do you do it uh hung
himself in his closet in a closet
at a hotel with a with a yeah it's not a
bad way to go out i mean if you're not
good you're like i don't know i would do
a gun you're in it buddy yeah pills is
the way to go once you do it you can't
go that's not true yeah [__] if
you're gonna do it [__] do it yeah
okay i kind of feel that way too and
also just i mean i don't know i don't
want to get too anyway so he uh so he uh
he says to me on this one of the few and
i have my phone
and i had just gotten a waterproof
casing and he says uh dude i'm listening
to widespread panic we have to go to red
rocks we've gotta have you have to
listen to song airplane and i and i
hadn't listened to widespread a long
time
and then i
within that time i'm testing out this
waterproof thing and i go to see if i
can record myself underwater and i
destroy the phone and that's the last
message i don't get to save the message
the phone dies i get nothing
right so i get on the beach that day for
a jog down in kaladesi i hope this is a
happy ending and i listen to airplane
yeah and i cannot hear that song without
thinking of my buddy
and i'm telling you right now that song
means so much to me uh that that's one
song and that got me back into how does
that song go how's that song
it's just [__] pretty no you wouldn't
know it you know you wouldn't know it
you wouldn't know so [__] pretty dude
i'll tell you right now i i'm going
through a big widespread panic phase and
right now uh the the album um
what's the red album with the chick on
it
hold on at least it's the song that you
like imagine your buddy died and nickel
every day the album every day yeah
everything yep dude hatfield postcards
all that [__] i cannot stop listening
please
wondering i mean it's that whole album i
put it on it sucks because i live next
to i live next to like hardcore partying
people who will if like they'll play
their music really yeah yeah sometimes
you know and i and my music is so it's
wilco
it's it's uh
it's widespread it's the dead
no argument here
you guys are older huh keep going like
choice
like bounce on the room sample in a jar
like oh my god come on come on like this
is what i'm talking about old school
sometimes i'm like [__] love it so
i've seen fish on probably eight or nine
times are they still alive like dude
when i was when i was a rookie when i'm
grabbing this mic like i'm [__] on
stage when i was a really good michael
i was a rookie with jeremy shockey yeah
and jeremy is a gohan savage right so we
are generally hockey played for miami so
so jeremy went to miami uh he was a
rookie for the giants i was a free agent
for the giants but jeremy and i are cut
from the exact same cloth so we would go
pretty damn hard all the time so it's a
new year's eve show in the in in the in
mathematics
yeah fish so yeah every new year
so we're we're backstage and we start
pulling down these js with them
and dude
yeah hold on you're telling me jeremy
shockey this is the fish [__] yeah yeah
dude i want to apologize to jeremy
shockey for ever thinking you were who
you are
you're the greatest guy that ever lived
hey [__] that is we were the coolest
thing you said when you fly when you
find people here's the coolest thing i
was sharing this to isla island my
youngest was into anime
and one day my kids love that [__] yeah
naruto and all that [__] she said she
goes she goes she shared it with someone
at school and they both
liked anime she gets in the car and she
goes
it's so cool
and think about don't think about anime
think about this about our careers right
yeah it's so cool
to share something you like with someone
and them to like it also it's such a fun
experience it's like the way we are
right now it's such a fun experience and
and i feel like and then the outside
i feel left out my feelings are hurt no
but think i'm also cooler think about
the feeling of when people go see you
live right yeah and they both sit down
and they sit down and and and they're
like uh
hey it's gonna be a good show that
energy yes of like like a phantom i'm
i'm a big fan of [__] i'm a big fan of
two i love that
yeah and and when you find [__] that
you're a fan like sugar and i are both
florida state fans right so for the
first time we ever connected walked into
the green room he's watching florida
state game i don't do not know him yeah
i walk in and i said
florida state he goes big fan i said i
went to florida state and he goes oh
yeah i saw him a huge fan and he was
like oh [__] and then uh the guy we were
working with uh
jay moore walked in and he goes why the
[__] are we watching this really and
yeah he goes and sigurda goes i got 100
bucks on
jay moore goes you're making fifty
dollars a show and you put a hundred
dollars on the game you're a [__]
idiot he walks out i look at the
cigarette i go welcome to the tour
and but but because we're you guys met
that's the first time but why is florida
state fan uh just not from there in
florida if you grew up in florida you
gotta pick one florida florida state or
miami yeah i've got a bunch of friends
that live down now orlando or usf that
live down in west palm and they're all
florida state fans yeah all of them you
don't have to florida's weird there's
every uh every every hurricanes fan
did not go to that school that's a
really great school i mean it's a great
school it's a private school it's a
great school year the smartest kids in
florida go to [__] university of
miami yeah yeah and i don't mean that
you think ray lewis won sap but it's a
private school yeah has texted me
aggressive lately really i
for new year's eve all right so let me
tell you this story about warren tap uh
secret time i'm not sure warren sapp
knows tom segura is a comedian
i think i might have sold it that he was
my producer and i was the talent
secretary
to this day
to this day he's the second time not
certain kind of doesn't respond we play
we play in this first sporting event of
the millennium uh uh january 1st 2000
2000 january 1st 2000 and the outback
bowl we're playing university of georgia
quincy
carter quincy carter quincy carter uh
yeah quarterback so we're playing them
and the outback bowl first boarding of
the millennium we go out and we party
[__] balls the day before the game
right new year's eve we go [__] hard
and i'm supposed to no this is two days
before the game this is like the 20th
30th or something right so um we're
[__] up and we're at a party with a
bunch of the buccaneers are out there
not mike also um and so we're out we're
bouncing around whatever else and i meet
warren zapp now i was all big ten and i
was supposed to do something with warren
sapp that next day your first team all
big ten yeah first team all big ten
ballerina so yeah i was supposed to do
something once app like some kind of
dealing with d-line instructional video
something something something i don't
know what it was but i knew about it so
i walk up to him and i'm like hey man
we're supposed to do something tomorrow
my name is matt mitrione nice to meet
you and the dude stands here with his
arms crossed and doesn't shake my hand
looks me and goes
are you done yet and just turned around
and walks away and from that moment i
swear to [__] christ next time i meet
that [__] spit in his [__]
mouth [__] him [__] that [__]
everybody his whole family [__] them all
right so i was just i was so salty right
yeah so and first of all i don't give a
[__] from a nobody but die dairy
disrespect me like that [__] you yeah
yeah yeah so they this [__] grudge
goes on for
12 years now hold on i'm going to say
grudge more on your side right no for
sure
because one set doesn't remember then
who the [__] i am right so i'm salty
foreign so i'm fighting in mainland
china in macau
i fight
fullback for lsu
oh sean jordan fight shawn jordan knock
him out in the first round right so i
knock him out 49 459 one second left in
the first round knock him out against
the wall bing fights over i'm walking
out i'm you know when you walk out like
that everybody's like giving you five or
whatever
way to go yeah cool walk walk walk walk
some guys man i turn around i'm holding
their hand thanks a lot blah blah it's
warren [__] sap and he's like [__]
great job man i [__] love you and i
was like that [__] yeah but i
was getting pushed in the back right i
was getting pushed in the back side to
get move out and i'm salty as [__] like
how dare that [__] touch me i was so
mad yeah and [__] china out of 14
years ago
why is warrants
and then i go back and i'm like let me
go [__] spit in that motherfucker's
mouth they're like that's probably not a
good decision buddy like you got a
little bit to lose now like
yeah you're probably right so he got
away without me [__] trying to well
you never went back in time no i i tried
to i could you if you bert put you on
the phone with warren you're so cool
then then i'm friends on my side so i
talked to mike right and i'm like hey do
i gotta tell your story so i told the
whole story and said i'm gonna be honest
with you
i love that [__] he's a guy i
[__] love him and he goes captains
one's captain officers
have to ride or die and he goes he goes
when i first showed up
after a handful of years
he wrote on something that he signed for
me
to the best white
tailback i've ever known but he but it
was white all captain white to the best
white tablet i've ever known okay
this is like after like two or three
years it wasn't long in the league but
it's still [__] all-star and when
mike retired
warren wrote him something i was like to
the best football player i've ever here
you go and i was like dude like like and
and mike was like dude he can be a [__]
like that to some people like i'm
putting words in my mouth he's right
he's probably personality and there's a
lot going on the fact that he was like
dude he's he's just uh he's just that
guy like now if i ever met him i'm sure
i'd be mad cool with them but for like
11 years i harbored mad animosity it
would be like two pit bulls but also
with uh warren sapp he used to be on air
so much more like nfl network and on and
they just took him out i think he's just
too he's like us he's like a podcast
very real yeah he's he's very first of
all he's very real and i will say i and
i don't i don't i don't i feel like
enough i don't know if he said this to
me but or if this is how he feels or
maybe i speculated
oh but he's a broken orbital oh for real
oh yeah that's a bad broken orbital
that's mad surgery right there oh my god
he has one eye
but it's got to be like it i know for a
fact that when i when i when i was just
a comic at the store and and people that
i'm friends with today
you'd say hi to them and they'd look
over your shoulder and look past you and
uh and then some like the glasses walk
in and they'd go yeah yeah yeah and walk
away you stop the conversation like yeah
cool man that's a real thing that
happens
imagine being a young black kid growing
up in florida
and and being treated a certain way in
the 70s in florida and then getting
success and having guys like the biggest
guys in in
wanting to no no no but like like the
guy that owns the lightning and all
these like the guy that owns outback
steakhouse come up and be like what's up
buddy i bet there's a little bit of you
that goes i'm gonna protect me yes from
all of this yeah because i don't trust
any of this [__] i don't by the way
warren did not say any of this i'm just
speculating i don't i don't i've hung
out with him a lot but i don't i'm just
speculating but i'm sure there's a he
protects himself but he is and i will
say this can be one of the sweetest
[__] dudes i bet once you get to know
him like he's gonna build up that armor
yeah my only thing with that is matt's a
young football player like he's a
football player dude you guys share the
common [__] yeah and i was supposed
to do something like it was on paper he
probably didn't know it obviously he may
not but whatever whatever it was
that was one of the lessons to me right
that i took
out of my athletic career my fighting
career i'm sorry my football career into
fighting was that at some point in time
nobody's going to give a [__] who you
ever were
right
so you might as well enjoy the moment of
when somebody wants to recognize you and
be like hey man for sure hey is there
anything worse when you're talking to
somebody it's weirded out but it still
happens where they're shaking it but
they're literally just looking for the
most like the next person like yeah
that's cool man you're telling a story
you can see him looking like oh there's
to your point sebastian you're like
[__] does not happen now i don't
know
that does not happen now but i'll be
very real
that energy defined
so much of who i am today i remember
getting fired from travel channel
redoing our house
not having a special anywhere uh
i remember all this all this moment of
being at the store not even past at the
store i wasn't even passed to the store
i was hanging out just a comic hanging
out and i've done a lot of stuff i was
probably 42 45 older oh yeah oh yeah
yeah and dudes
dudes who
definitely
uh would never say they did this who are
still at the store
and would and would argue they're my
friend i watched them do it to me
there's a handful of people that did not
i'll tell you i know i'll be very real
bill burr rogan uh john mulaney randomly
johnna mullaney if you talk to me talk
to you guys
like like i'm like i'm not gonna point
out everyone it's a handful
but i remember the people that did i
definitely do and i
and i never forget it burt i won i
download all of that like he does with
warren sabb and chase storm dude i
download all that and i never forget it
ali wong
looks you in the eyes when she talks to
you has a conversation with you
uh and talks to you and you'll be the
first one to go uh i'm gonna i don't
think i have another spot ali's [__]
great
john mulaney caught me off guard
because he was so genuine and by the way
i think i got so conditioned to people
doing that to me that i was expecting it
yeah sam tripoli never once
like just a [__] real [__]
but but it happened and man
and there's a humbling feeling when you
go to the store you have a bad set you
perform shirtless you get looked over
everyone you look at your shoulder you
go back to your house which is 1500
square feet at the time we were living
in like 500 square feet you're
renovating our house and
and you just lay in bed going so this
may not work out yes
yep and and i never forget that's why
that's why for you know i'm ride or die
for you like there's a few people who
and again tough sell when you come from
ufc into comedy or the comedy store and
you're friends with rogan you're improv
and laugh after you're in spots it's a
tough sell man and i get it but the
people that were cool to me i never
forget it the people who are mean to me
i never forget it man it's it's hard to
it's hard to let it is hard to let go i
was with uh i was with shane gillis
and uh
uh
secret time so secret time yep so we did
the off record we did the podcast we did
i mean i hope i hope i'm not sharing too
many secrets no please we did a podcast
fully loaded and nikki glazer was on the
on there uh the cast yeah the cast yeah
and and
and he was being a little salty to nikki
and everyone was like what's going on
and he was he goes like i remember what
you said about me on stern what'd he say
uh what she was when shane got cancelled
on saturday live on saturday live and
then she went on and said some stuff and
then shane said
kind of checked her on it and she said
i'm i'm sorry i didn't mean to and then
shane goes you know i listen to it again
it wasn't that bad but that what happens
is that first time it [__] stings and
you're like you're like
and you don't even read the whole thing
you don't even hear the whole there's
just something all of a sudden it's just
the one word that you're like god damn
it what the [__] fat alcoholic what did
you say and and you're like
i know sometimes i've misread things
that people say about me but i i mean
it's uh it sticks with you and it
defines who you are for the rest of your
life you know i can't but you can use it
as fuel i use that view i'm like okay
we'll see what's up where are you going
to me i go we'll see you in six years
of
vulnerability
you guys a have to wear on your sleeves
on a daily basis
uh because the internet is the gift and
the curse but also
you guys expose yourself even way before
the internet like you can bomb you can
flop you can kill it you never know you
never how the delivery goes or anything
else and then and then from that like
like you're only as good as your last
show or your last performance so
whenever it goes and then it's saying
you just don't know it's not accurate
say you don't crush it how you think you
if i bomb tomorrow night i still got a
body of work by the way yeah but i'm
saying that right i can't get up but
three but
but mentally it took you forever to work
into that position yes right the anxiety
that's similar to fighting yeah what
bert was talking about earlier
earlier yeah when you release a special
yeah you put that out you think it you
know you're like here you go everybody
and you know your fans and people are
going to [__] a lot of and then once
you especially you're doing different
promos so you're getting outside your
fan base so you need a lot of different
eyeballs on there man that's got to be
so the thickest skin that's got to be so
hard because you have how do you deal
with it you have so many critical eyes
and
your your specials are something that
like
every joke starts sometimes that means
something to you i'm guessing right they
don't just come out of nowhere unless
it's an observation that nobody else has
made and you have like a rather unique
um objective and satirical view on it uh
or a wrinkle of some form but it's also
like remember when i first met chris i
asked chris i go i go you don't do any
drugs you don't drink he goes no i said
well
then how do you escape uh julia
i was like chris who come on as soon as
you said donald trump's i was like
there's a chris that does that
like how do you how do you escape the
cynical
part of your mind that can create the
madness that you create
like you have to be able to escape it
like how do you know but my thing
whether special stand up whatever it is
pictures
trust me whatever you guys say to me i'm
harder on myself you guys aren't telling
me anything i don't know
but when you want to see
when it goes to people talking [__]
i'm so down for the guys if someone
talks [__] on you're special i will stop
them in the [__] tracks someone goes
bad on chris it ain't happening in front
of me man
i don't give a [__]
it's all i always get these wrong
subjective or objective subjective it's
all subjective
so like i don't know stand up a stand up
and there are it's like music
okay drake sucks
look i i you got to get
you just got to like hope that you stand
up against enough waves that it doesn't
knock you down and just go i hope i my
whole thing was like when i did my first
special i was like i just want to
increase my fan base by like five
percent correct that'd be a lot of money
to me specials are just advertisements
to see me on the road well they're not i
i wouldn't say they're advertising yo
yours aren't now the level you're at
they're not where i'm at it is yes oh
yeah oh yeah like yours are bodies of
work i think they're gonna
i'm very precious with i'm very precious
with stand up and meaning that uh
it's the only thing i do
that i really love like i mean it seems
like that's the genuine art is stand up
for people like y'all it seems like
stand up is the pure factor like [__]
with everything else but don't [__] with
stand up well yeah you could take
podcasts away or whatever else i do as
long as i have stand up i'm good
yeah i mean i did this without
podcasting and was and was i was pot
committed before podcasting i never like
uh god committed apocalypse
before podcasting podcasting is just fun
for me i really enjoy it like
and it's a good way to hang out with
friends it's a good way to catch up with
friends it's like if i go to austin i'm
probably not gonna i mean if i go to
dinner with rogan it's different because
everyone's staring at you but also you
me wrote like we're all so busy in our
own [__] we have families
hanging out can rogan have a normal life
in austin yeah yeah i mean to joe he's
not going to be your normal life his
life is has changed 100 percent
when i went out there i told him so
incrementally
to a point where like you remember joe's
been famous since we were in high school
like i mean
and i'm making that work that was from
for the record is the best show the best
sitcom that's ever been made it is andy
dick
the best that's great i fell in love i
watched that when i was a little kid i
watched a and e i watched it on a and e
when i first got into stand-up it is so
great it is such a great [__] sitcom
phil hartman andy andy
[__] uh and joe played a great
character for him too
um that show is huge so he goes from
that time when i first got into stand up
what did you do before i was in college
so you weren't from college you went
from college you went from the machine
to bird christ to the machine i was well
i went i i think it's it defines who i
am on stage because i went i was this
party animal college i moved to new york
and i was like
to get in stand up okay i did stand up
once in tallahassee at a place called
potbellies uh and i did like 30 20 30
minutes and i did all stream of
consciousness i closed the show i had
like four comics one before me now were
you a known commodity because uh because
of the article okay so the article came
out
and uh that changed everything right i
mean game changer game changer like
overnight games like what was your life
before to afterwards if you can if
you're going to uh
you got in free at bars in florida
after after i was after i walked in and
the
offensive line was standing at yani's at
the bar and they were like this is the
guy we're here because of you up here
we're doing shots wow and like and it
was like everyone knew warren sapne or
warren worked on knew who i was everyone
knew i was the i was one of the probably
10 most famous people at that school
when i graduated and now put that in
perspective this is 1997. this is before
the internet really i mean the internet
was around but it wasn't it was it was
so me and storm island were not we're on
the internet either so yeah yeah and so
and so it was like this article came out
everyone at florida state read it i was
the guy in the article i was on the
thing with my shirt off open in the with
a k
can i see that there's a yeah it's a six
and a half page article in florida can
we give a statue yeah uh i know you have
dion sanders can we get a birthday party
sugar is doing my birthday present right
there will be a picture of me holding
the spear in the middle of campus
shirtless from my [__] i did the i
did the same place i saw nirvana i
performed at the same place i saw
nirvana
nirvana smashing pumpkins at the
today the top party at the number one
party school in the country that's boom
[__] amazing
see the pictures oh man
give me a lifetime pass but i did stand
up once at potbellies i said in the
article i wanted to try stand up this
radio show put on a stand-up show how
old are you at december 20
5 25. and so uh
exactly that's not it that's not that's
from i didn't that's me that's me which
one right the one in the center
you were a wild shirtless always hey let
me ask you this bird were your shirtless
at college parties too yeah i was only
sure let me ask you i grew up in florida
though that's always thank you hey brett
lemmons where'd you grow up at tampa
tampa one of the best i loved yeah
cities
tampa improv holler improv love it
shout out to
uh obviously big boy right right you're
not winning bodybuilding contest but
once that article came out ladies were
coming nope nope still not nope oh wow
i've had sex with six people women women
i don't know why i said people women in
your entire life six with six women your
entire life i'm just not a sex guy like
i'm like a like i'm a regular hang on
let me let me rephrase that you're
hanging out
i'm i'm a party guy i like to party i
like the party i like to black out i
like to have a but your goal is not to
get girls it will
no well i think it was i think it was my
first sexual experience was not uh
like my tracking ninth grade tenth grade
eleventh grade was like [__] [__]
[__] [__] yeah and then i lose my
virginity it goes horrifically wrong it
can't be worse than that man
raped at nine years old after his
[__] meet me in the woods story i'm
not telling that
the uh but i i lose my jenny it doesn't
go well i am the reason it doesn't go
well i uh discard you it and it well it
changed my perspective and i was like
i'm a girlfriend guy so i like i was
like
if i'm gonna [__] someone i want i want
to make sure that they're not gonna tell
people about it i need practice i need
to practice with them i need to let them
know this one's not gonna be much
so i i meet a girl i date it i mean i
lose my journey i date a girl for a full
year after that don't have sex with her
go to college meet a girl have sex with
her date her for like five years
cheats on me and
which is in line for like why i haven't
[__] a lot of people is because she
cheats on me i'm like i still must
[__] soccer sex meet another girl
date her move to new york have like one
one night stand uh
maybe
two it's weird because you're not a bad
looking guy no but i just it you know i
couldn't ferociously i couldn't if you
looked like peter just i couldn't turn
it off i was never i could never get
comfortable enough to be the person that
[__] the person that says the life of
the party
like to this day i mean look and by the
way i'm i'm trying to not i'm in therapy
right now i'm trying to not work in
absolutes because like i say to everyone
i never drink and drive uh during coven
when i did rogan's yeah i got high as
[__] drove when like seven days in
cove and no one's on the street all
right i do roast the only guy you're
like you get a drink i was like i drove
here i shouldn't he was like oh you'll
be fine i get hammered nobody's on the
road whenever i get on the 101 there's
no one no one's yeah
but i just
my thing is i can never turn it off with
a chick
the the um personality part like i i
would i could never be the guy that they
didn't take you seriously so to this day
if i get a dm
from a chick no i want to try not to act
in absolutes but for real if i get a
chick from text from a dm
i am
party fungi brother i i just friend zone
right away i don't know
i'm not the guy i'm not the guy that i
could never i couldn't i just my brain
doesn't operate in that way to this day
my wife and i have never like sexted
we've never we've never had phone sex
she doesn't send me like dirty pigs
are you [__] kidding me so you're not
you're so nervous so you got no piece of
kids like is that because
like it's your birthday [__] life is
that because of you or is that because
of her as well because of me and i'm i'm
pretty like i'm bro send her dick pic
i'm pretty it's her birthday [__] let's
do it after a picture of that cactus you
know what i'm my black belt and dick
pics the way i make it hey listen i
wouldn't ask for it
that makes me want to drink that i only
drink whiskey too that's what i'm saying
but uh i'm not i'm just and i'm not i'm
saying i'm i'm not saying that i've
never been this guy i've been married
for a long time i'm married before dms
were real you know but like but i like i
just i wasn't a chat room
guy back in the old school days it's
just not my it's not your thing that's
all right it's not my thing and so like
i never got any [__] off of it like uh
but i'm a regular person i'm not gay or
anything but i just like when you're
bored
honestly man like most of the time
most of the time
the good time guy is going to find out
i'm gay then just not good at getting
there
the third is like hold on you've never
forget
but like most of the time the good time
guys not the [__] guy no right you're
just a let's figure out who what's the
[__] the good time guy right but like
that makes your diploma but let me tell
you something there's a there's a
there's also there's a group of chicks
that i only kissed because we were
shotgunning marijuana like there's a
group of chicks that's how you worked it
out like oh i just wasn't i was just i'm
not i was with a dude i won't say his
name i won't say his name i won't say
his name
and i was with the dude i was with the
dude right and we were about to work a
very famous comedian
what the [__] are you doing well they're
not gonna know okay okay you know what
famously
yeah i actually love him by the way i
defend him too
i'm so sorry i
i've had some drinks i'm sorry i thought
we were hooking up oh i'm not in a
circle i can't wait to circle now
careful i can cut
nope go ahead all right so uh we were
this is we're talking we were in our 20s
but we were the kids back then and we
were hooking up we're hanging out with
these chicks and we're trying to like
hook hook up with him and and and i feel
like he's a closer he is a closer yes
and he goes he goes hey man turn it off
and i went what and he goes turn it off
the show's over let's let this happen
and i was like and i remember going
turning i can't get to where you are
yeah where you do i can't get from like
the serious eyes like i can't do that
yeah pussy's for closer
there should be a t-shirt
for sure
[__] for closers needs to be a
[__] t-shirt hey that's emergency
tough shirt to wear in a mall but that's
that's i'm sure they're aware at the
[__] parent teacher conference yeah
there's a cat on it and it says [__]
for closer no no just as cat says it's
foreclosers yeah so then nobody really
losers
the uh but yeah i just uh i
i don't know i mean to this day it's
like
uh whatever
i try not to talk in absolutely
something that's like my one thing but
uh you like your therapist
uh listen all out me
already know i go there's certain people
i can't say their name because we're
doing it on video chat oh and if someone
steals my thread and it'll ruin my
career correct it's like it's like it's
like there's certain people like you
also got to go in person
when ari drugged me i couldn't just
[__] talk about that in therapy yeah
because all of a sudden someone steals
that threat and that is the biggest
podcast that's bert christ you're
talking for an hour with a dude who's
listening about what it felt like to be
drugged by by his best friend
and and so like there's a lot of things
i just i couldn't share in therapy
because i was i because i only are your
best friend no no no oh no are you oh no
or he's not my best friend but tommy's
my best friend but he's one of my
closest friends if it's my space are you
in your top eight oh yeah all right he's
in my top eight right now in real life
and i know but it's myspace it's very i
know that i know that ari is for a lot
of people listening
i understand what people think about ari
but like my assistant we just went to
mark norman's bachelor party that was a
great comic but my assistant said to me
the last day he's like we're having a
beer at the airport and their flight
gets delayed mark
chodroso and ari's flight gets laid and
they come over and my assistant goes my
assistant's a solid [__] dude talked
about him and he goes i met him he goes
i wanted to hate him
i said what he goes i wanted to hate ari
and i said yeah and he goes he's the
sweetest guy in the world he is there's
a part of ari that is
that is people don't see it he you know
arya say whatever he wants about me but
i doubt i don't understand the two of
you i don't understand oh i kind of do
really why i have no i have no ill will
towards them i know at all me me and i
have done shows together
um but ari say something gets taken out
of context and i don't have his number
we're not boys at all no and he'll text
me he'll call me or text me he'll text
me like hey man he'll be like that he'll
be like this came out the one thing i
don't do is [__] on other i saw that i
saw that that was [__] [__] but
it's not real but but but also yeah no
it's not real it's not real and it's
well that's what was [__] about it i
was like he called me about it and told
me
i don't care you know i have no ill will
towards arya at
he did a all in indianapolis a handful
years ago and we went down to meet him
or went down to the show and we just
happened to be recognized in the front
um and dude he was [__] doped us we
went out we went drinking afterwards
and he was he was really cool and
respectful to everybody i was around
we've just
all the same mutual friends that's the
podcast i want to see just you and him
the you and him i would love to see that
podcast because i know you and i know
him and i i think i surround me like the
people that hate me are
textbook uh sociopaths like i mean i
just i know who hates me like i'm not
saying look if you're listening this
you're like i'm not a fan of birds i
also understand you but if you go if you
i hate bert i have problems with birds
usually usually you're in the group the
small group of people that go
uh this is an issue i have that i need
to clean up correct and i'm i'm
projecting on bert yeah like you you
need to see birds therapy and i and
and ari's an interesting guy because
like like i said
uh my my daughters hate him my daughters
hate him and my wife hates him he'll
never come he'll never come he'll never
oh that's right i was on the show right
never come to my house what was they
dropping to you molly that's right it
was on the podcast right it was on my
podcast yeah and everyone's like release
it and that's this is what sucks about
the internet but you go
you don't i i know better what you want
to see than you you're not going to want
it's not just it's going to hurt it's
not what you think it's also going to
hurt more it's not i watched it and man
when you see in my eyes when you realize
what happened so you started feeling
some kind of way and you're like man i
feel [__] weird
and i was like i was like
i was like
i feel like [__] weird and
then he said by the way if if you watch
it i'm doing it justice right now but
he's like do you do you but if you watch
it it is he's high on molly and he's
saying it high on molly and he's like do
you do you and i was like i was like
yeah why and he's like
he's like maybe
you you can't be mad and i was like what
he's like maybe i put something in your
drink
when i realized that moment i realized
is not cool it's not cool it's like it's
like the same thing about like no i'm
way closer with you than not even close
way closer with you i love you yeah i
don't love ari i don't know him that way
when when i heard that that pissed me so
once you reach your friend i was like
what the [__] are you doing i'm just
trying to hash it up but i don't know so
once you once you recognize it your
response was he has to get on a flight
too and he's around his kids it's fairly
complicated because uh he had cosby but
because i you know i'm i'm i'm on molly
um
he's having a panic attack i have to be
on a flight it's not my it's in my house
in his house around his kids and my kids
and wife are there
but bums me out so much
is
ari was like uh
i don't know i don't want to get too
deep into it but like he was very
friendly in our house like when he
showed up he was always traveling he
always had a backpack he was always
doing laundry you know and and like him
and isla connected and they they found
him funny and it was fun and then you
know in one stupid thing he did he made
it so that now my daughters hate his
guys understandably understandably my
wife hates his guts and and i had a
month i had a month where i'd you know
like like i called whitney cummings and
the next day it happened to talk i
talked pretty intensely with her about
it and then
talked to a few people talked to joe i
talked to tommy i talked to everyone
about everyone like kind of trying to
round your feelings out be like i'm not
like to be like this happened to me i
don't how do i feel about it how should
i feel how much i feel about it what did
tommy say about it
that's such a massive i'm not gonna say
anything anyone said only because the
only thing i'll say that anyone said was
whitney cummings whitney cummings he's
very smart said he said
you are not to release that podcast
first most important you do not want to
become a meme and i went oh yeah because
the look on my face when i get a roofie
it is uh
that would be she's correct that'd be me
but also as are his friend y'all did you
release it's not going to be no that was
so so that was to me looking out for ari
you don't want to release it that was
the conversation i had with whitney was
not whitney was not in that group uh the
conversation with joe and and tom was
more like because we were in the middle
of sober october and and we just started
starting october and we were like what
what do we do and
and so you guys take that [__] seriously
sober october yeah oh yeah oh yeah yeah
sobriety it's not that hard but uh but
so in 30 days dudes do it forever yeah
sometimes
never done yeah chris yeah sober life
yeah so but uh but it was kind of
complicated of like of like how do we
how do you handle this and then i made
the decision i watched it and it was
just so bad i made the decision not to
release it and i was like i was like i
don't i don't want to ruin him forever
i'm with you and listen so i don't know
why that well i i i just been spoken
about
i've talked about my wife went on what
i'm saying obviously this isn't the
first time it's been here oh no no no no
no no well documented i mean i think
i've talked about how long ago was it
before the pandemic three years ago so
what's his response to it i'm very
apologetic like dude i [__]
then right before sober october ended i
i just left a uh what's the purple gym
uh antenna fitness i was after playing
at fitness with shane torres he was a
terrible brother and he i was just
running yeah and uh
he called and i answered it and his
first thing he said was did i ruin our
friendship
and i was like as soon as he said that i
went he's sorry yes and uh and ari is a
complex dude man and and there's a lot
of things he's done
yeah everyone is
but uh and i said i said i don't know
he's also a wild dude too like we went
on this bachelor party the first time
he pulled me aside and he goes
afterwards his last weekend yeah okay he
goes uh they're friends just so you know
i will not be drugging you i promise you
i went i got to be down so i was like
thank you because i
there is the weird part about when you
get drugged
when you get drugged it's
nothing safe anymore like nothing is
safe i've put away drinks where i go i'm
i'm out like i get it i'd get out of
places because once you get drugged once
then you're hypersensitive you're really
sensitive but
like i said
it bums me out that i actually talked to
him about you this weekend it bums me
out that you got cause i was like i was
like i'm going back doing shops thing
and he was like okay and i was like i
was like what's going on and he was like
i don't know he had some things saying i
was like i i
you are one of the sweetest dudes i know
i'll never i'm not gonna back down from
ever saying that
you make me giggle hard as [__] you
really do and look there are a few
things i i treasure in life
and uh
if you're a cool dude and you make me
giggle it's the only reason i'm friends
with rogan i mean but dead serious joe
rogan makes me giggle and he's a re he
is top-notch one of the coolest dudes
you'll ever meet
very selfless tom sagura
the coolest dude alive who makes me
giggle nonstop
i don't need much out of a friend i
don't even know him i need to know him a
little better i wouldn't waste your time
and so
[Laughter]
but yeah but like uh when it comes to it
it doesn't make sense so he's always
been nice to me like to my face he's i
think he i don't know look i'm not going
to speak for anyone like it's my thing
i'm trying to do i'm trying a lot of
things in therapy right now but here's
my other thing here i don't care i
understand i'm all set on friends you
know what i'm saying it's that's the
other part that you got to be cool with
as being a when you're a man as you go
well i don't need a more friend i
remember uh
paul f tomkin well i should not have
said his name but
[Applause]
paul tompkins and i had beef right and
that's
comedian very talented [__] very
talented and we had beef and it was he
said she said he said he said um and we
didn't know who was right or wrong and
and then he just emailed me one day and
he was like it doesn't matter who's
right or wrong and also we don't need to
be friends like like we can be also just
two men who never speak and that's also
all good and i was like i was like yeah
you're right man like i don't need to be
i'm someone who needs to be best friends
with everyone i want to be your best
friend i want you to like me like i told
you yeah that's that's the vibe you get
off yeah i i don't like when someone
dislikes me like i'm like i don't get it
you know what i'm like
i'm pretty chill i remember i remember
hearing i remember hearing uh
hardcore secret time and by the way two
of my friends mark norman and shane
gillis and and you know and already
three of my friends are on rogan and
they're talking about fully loaded and
someone's like you know a lot of guys
[__] on bert for taking his shirt off
and all i heard was they do
yeah you're like
[__] wait who does that yeah and rogan
goes they do and he was like well you
know what and like they just tried to
skate over it yeah like i was like what
are people saying about me in new york
yeah i thought i wasn't cool that's
but like it's funny the things you hear
and you're like i don't need everyone to
love me
that's hard to [__] that's hard
that's a hard but if someone has a
problem like if i saw ari wherever at a
comedy club i would go what's going on
dude what's wrong with it
it's it's his own issues you know what
i'm saying so he has to carry that
burden i don't i don't think about it i
feel that right but i think he's a great
company i think i think it would be
really brilliant to have him and you do
a podcast i would love to see that
possibility because
that'd be different have some drinks
talk find out what's going on i would
love that i said that to him uh when we
were in and what we'll call it
maybe i did i don't know it's pretty
drunk you know i'll tell you you know
from
listening to your guys's conversation
yeah
i can understand the similarities
between
comedy stand-up
and fighting
um the vulnerability the exposure um the
like someone calling you out yeah like
do or like people you care about or
people that are in your circle and
you're like dude what the [__] and it's
like a feeling of sabotage but at the
same time it's just a perspective and
like you have to know yourself better
not to really be that worked up about it
but it's still a powerful position for
somebody else to take and you take it
personally it's very imaginative
what do you have it's very hard not to
be vulnerable i i there's i mean like
but you that's why you take your shirt
off because you capitalize on the
vulnerability that's what you do you
disarm the vulnerability of your
position maybe i don't know i don't
really i wish i had some insight to
anything i ever did i know for a period
there was a there was a time where like
i would get in my head about people not
liking me like people on the internet
like not liking me and i just i just had
to i mean once again through therapy i
had to remove myself from that and go it
was it was based on our old house
remember my old house yeah there was a
one it was a one-way street coming up
and uh it was around the same time and
uh there was my two issues with people
not liking me on the internet like
people not like
it was like people were like i like tom
[__] bert and then it would bother me
i'd go why would you so you and tom have
always been guys yeah yeah and i was
like super close and i was like why
wouldn't they like both tom and tom said
the same thing sorry tom but tom said
the same thing like why would they think
we're best friends why wouldn't they
like both of us right like
tom said the same thing especially if
tom [__] with you if you like tom and
tom's such a big fan of you why would it
and and i remember at the same time we
had an issue with people driving the
wrong way up our streets
do that [__] and parking the wrong way
on one way that [__] me up too it would
drive me it drove me nuts and i would
sit outside with a glass of wine and i
would get irate and my i and my and i
would think of things i would do to them
i would think of things i'd do to [__]
them up and i bought i bought uh
i did a lot of things i lost my mind
about it i'm going to do it
but the same way you would online about
the leading comments or commenting back
the same like this out of control
behavior of like
and my therapist said to me it's always
can you he said can you change can you
stop people from driving the wrong way
and i said no he goes then you need to
let that go because that's something you
can't change so let it go and just
realize that that's not you you're
wasting energy and when he said that's
not you i realized i don't i've never
really left a negative comment ever ever
yeah i don't know
oh that's not me oh that's not me
and then i'd see people drive the other
way so then so then
i so i'm processing this and i'm walking
the girls to school one day and a dude
flies up the street
the wrong way and i don't i don't this
one
i had this water bottle in my hand i had
this water bottle in my hand and i s and
and he [__] flies up and the girls
are their babies he didn't come close to
him but he drove fast enough that it was
it was like just on your thing and i
went hey [__] and i had this in
my hand and i think and he gets out of
his car it's an older man and i think
i'm gonna swing this and hit him in the
head with it he sees me and he starts
[__] screaming me so i live in this
[__] neighborhood i go to that
starbucks i'll drive up this street if i
[__] want to because i [__] live
here and i remember going like well this
guy's really pop committed i was like
wow and so and and i'm like i'm not
fighting this guy i might lose and he's
much older than me there's only one way
to go
to jail or not and my wife's with me and
and she's like it's a one-way street sir
and he goes [__] you when he gets in his
car [__] you he gets in his car he
drives off now i'm in my head that i
lost this fight for a solid day i have
lost this fight
two weeks later
i see the same dude
with his wife
in front of their house and he's in a
walker wow he had had a massive stroke a
massive [__] stroke you thought
that's what and i and i thought
i thought i guess i
i got you [__] guys
so so let me let me just have a stroke
and i went i go and i all i thought was
all all these things i can't afford but
that's when when you have that much
misery and you drive backwards on my
street moderately the same conversation
we have we even live in a neighborhood
right there's my neighborhood is just
one 90 degree road right it's uh
58 houses on the entire street entire
neighborhood 58 houses um and this one
we don't have any speed bumps do you
play disco on this huh do you play disc
golf no but if you're asking let's
[__] do it because i think me start
becoming best friends yeah i think it's
happening for sure i knew you would so
um so there's a one degree turn there's
only one turn 90 degrees they live on
the far corner of the neighborhood right
and i tell them listen man there's kids
all the [__] time on the street we
have 87 kids within two houses
[__] chill out don't drive 40 miles
an hour drive 25. chill out if you have
a problem with it since you live on a
corner just take the outside streets
they're big they're big roads no problem
i've been in the house three [__]
times i am at the point where i want to
stab their [__] tires i want to pop
their [__] and i'm like you know what
don't they're a rental
i'm an elitist they might not be here
forever but at the same time like maybe
they just don't know the [__] common
courtesy of a [__] neighborhood i
don't [__] know and i try so [__]
but hey i'm telling you hold on let me
talk about [__] popping off
i smell you what you got we were hanging
out with the sociopathic dad one time
right is this is it this is my
hypothetically the guy killed someone
one time right
legit
legit hypothetically and the guy was
a little off kilter
and we come back from a concert and we
all parked our cars at the school
and we're out outside the cars we just
got dropped off on a bus oh no i was at
the irvine improv and so we all come
back we all dropped our cars up at the
school and we're out there we're getting
we're getting in our cars but we're all
having a drink where we just got dropped
off in a party bus we're all having a
good time and an old man comes out in
his underwear like boxers out of his
house he has a dead tree in front of his
house if you know where i want my kids
went to school you know who this guy is
he opens his door and he goes hey
shut the [__] up we're trying to sleep
in here and the sociopath goes
[__] i know where you live and
i'm not done [__] with you and i went
oh and then you hear the wife go get
back in the house
and i went oh my god that's not the way
you want to go to bed going he knows
where i live yeah you're like
[__] live and i remember everyone was
like everyone in their cars let's just
go everyone's like i know you do not
want anyone to know where you live holy
[__] i pulled a gun on a homeless guy
one time
[Laughter]
and i said what [__] transition dude
i saw the look of not giving a [__] in
someone's eyes and i went i am not that
kind the homeless guy was like i don't
give a [__]
what are you gonna do fire away
[__]
[Music]
we had a porta potty and they told me
they're like hey man you gotta you're
gonna have to put a lock on this porta
potty because homeless people are
sitting here all day we're flipping this
porta potty like twice a day
it's like that many people are sitting
in here so one night we come home drunk
from my sister's house me and the girls
and and i and i see
the [__] lock is off and we've
forgotten to lock it and there's a light
inside our [__] border the guy's on
his [__] cell phone taking a [__] at
like midnight in my porta potty so i go
over and i take the lock and i turn it
and i lock it
goes
what are you going to do with him when
you get let him go like and i go oh my
god i just caught him
i was like [__] we caught one baby what
am i gonna do with it
oh [__] it oh she got a gun
no no i pulled a gun not that guy oh no
was it a
so is he still there
no i had a homeless guy one time i was
trying to fix my fence and he goes and
he was sitting i used to live everyone
knows where i lived that's why i had to
move but uh we lived on an alley yeah
and there's a homeless guy in the alley
and i was trying to change the fence
i had to fix the fence to my gardener
we lived by a jack-in-the-box and we had
this big bird of paradise and the
gardener cut down the bird of paradise
and now i can see a jack in the box
that's a tree it's like it's kind of
jacketed paradise is a tree yeah yeah
yeah yeah very big and like
dissolves noise it's great now suddenly
all i see is a jack-in-the-box sign and
when you walk in my backyard you see a
jacket that means you're not in a good
neighborhood right and the guy goes the
guy goes uh i go why'd you do that and
he goes why don't i go i see the was
fine the sign and he goes you don't like
jack in the box like i don't think
that's what this is about i love jack of
the box
why don't you like jack in the box
like no
jack in the box [__] by the way
we don't have jack in the boxes in
indiana as far as i know i might walk
out
i just sat in my pool the first night
and all i saw was the jack in the box i
don't want this is not what it's like
you're a motel sick
so there's i'm sorry i've got to put a
fence up to block the jack of the box
sign
man and there's a it's a good thing that
we all have smooth sacks get listen it's
a smooth sack summer it's called
transition baby when you're playing in
the summer sun make sure you escape from
pubes to your bomb that's right this
summer to keep your balls cool while
still looking hot with manscape the
leader below the belt groom is making
sure we all have a ball this summer by
giving our pants partners everything
they need to stay fresh dive head first
into smooth sack summer by going to
manscape.com for 20 off free shipping
with the code cfc the manscape
performance package 4.0 you get the
trimmer you get the nose trimmer the air
trimmer you get their liquid
formulations to keep that freshness even
the hottest barbecues this summer
manscape even threw in two free gifts
the in the performance package 4.0 the
manscape boxers and shed travel bag all
right we got you covered man get 20 off
and free shipping with code cfc at
manscape.com that's 20 and free shipping
with the code cfc manscape.com it's a
smooth sack summer boys get on board or
get left behind i'm going to tell you
this man i got a piece so hard
or [__] up until
i'm going to be up [__] time i don't
know what time can i have met the
[__] bernie be honest with you
uh before i [__] tore my ball second
party two weeks ago i had the biggest
squirrels nest of all time dude it was
like it was like a small
party in my pants because it was
everything went nuts in there it was
[__] bananas
i gotta get this [__] i tell myself all
the time just [__] order it make
bringing some money i'm not even [__]
well by the way
shout out to manscape there does it
really not cut your balls it's got the
skin safe technology by the way you're
you're welcome manscapes and then by the
way thank you for all your years of
support on the bird cast so what's
beautiful about this thing is this light
this light is [__] awesome so if
you're shaving your nuts over the toilet
which is where i shave my nuts that
light lights up everything so all those
hairs that you don't see yeah it lights
them up and the skin safe technology
technically i mean it it just won't cut
you it doesn't matter i'm not going to
it's a ceramic blade up top so what
you're telling me right now is that when
brandon gets back i'm going to go to the
bathroom right now and shave my balls i
know and i come back and it was after
hey and they won't they won't cut my
nuts they don't go in first try to cut
your nuts like i'm sure that i'm not
going to try to yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah no no it's like that
though you can literally see
them tight
but yeah every now and then
i've only shaved my wife's [__] uh yeah
that's how i work i don't know how do
you know yeah like
what am i gonna let her go somewhere
else yeah she's she's [__] 50 too
she's gonna you're not gonna go to the
[__] get watched so so my wife gets
my ass
there's chicks in this town have seen
your [__] like that's [__] weird i
got waxed one time full brazilian yeah
yeah
one talk sip soup clip of the year for a
podcast no for television this i used to
be i used to be talented let's talk
about it hey
what was it like uh it's amazing
your farts are so much louder there's no
hair there so it just goes
crap
[__] clapping what was what was that
what did it feel like on your balls in
your taint uh i couldn't stop jerking
off i could not stop jerking off and i
will tell you
i got out of one of the six chicks i
think i've had sex with i got how old
are you
right now we're dead no then
i was 26.
yeah i was 27. i was 27.
you can pull it up pull it up i [__]
whisper
yeah burp pressure
burp raise your hands it's the funniest
thing i've ever done i'm gonna take that
the machine's the funniest thing i've
ever done number two without a doubt uh
come on is the machine the funniest
thing you ever done because it became so
famous or is it is it because yeah yeah
yeah so look at this so we can't
actually play this but we'll see it on
that's yours yeah that's me i always
should be young my voice is so high in
this i used to talk like this
uh do you smoke cigarettes i don't i
drink a lot i think i have acid reflux
yo so look how young i am i know that's
you right there yeah i'm not crazy so
somebody very close to my family just
called me and was like hey man i think i
have bladder cancer and i was like dude
get the [__] out are you serious and
it's like yeah and i was like dude
there's no way we genetically i was like
we we don't have cancer in our in our
lives that's your that's your coin first
right my coin purse but yeah if you show
and by the way i wish i had the oh my
gosh yeah it's pretty right was that was
that pain for real that's real response
is real pain it's wide awake now flip it
forward a bit and you'll see them wax
myself so i heard i heard steve carell
was 100 accurate response as well watch
this well you can't wax man's chest oh
this is your this is your your balloon
you watch it
so if you watch them wax my [__]
it is
legit
it is just very realness and i think
that's why it's funny do they go up or
down they it they that's that's them
pointing the wax on the wax is super hot
that's just the wax and now me this is
me oh my god you can see the are you
pulling the balls forwards i'm holding
my balls
you can see it they pull up her back
yeah
if you if you could hear the audio it's
[__] holy [__]
but wait watch her because she's not
done and she's just like now cleaning up
back there oh my god and she's like
that's more on my [__] that's what my
[__] that's what my [__]
i don't think you have i don't think you
had nerves on your balloon not i thought
i didn't think it was supposed to hurt
back there okay let me put hot wax on
your [__] you'll feel it is that an
offer yeah that's
watch here's the best part of this whole
video
is
as i get
that's all my ass hair but she just
wouldn't stop and she just couldn't
she's putting [__] in her wax in my
[__]
it was uh that same day i got a colonic
did you really yeah i got a clonic that
same day so
there was enough stuff jerking off some
i could not stop jerking off and i got
like six [__] the next night
next night to ja rules
[Music]
this main event i got six [__] the
same girl same girl i remember waking
her up in the middle of the night be
like are you using another one hey hey
she's a cool chick i don't know what
she's doing with her life they should
have that thing on instagram where you
can like privately follow people
yeah everybody else knows like there's
one check i dated who does not is not on
social media at all
yeah yeah you know you know what i think
they should do when it comes to social
media i feel like there should be that
position that that every every current
significant other should know hey man i
want to follow these two significant
significant others i just want to know
what they're up to that's all i just
want to see how they're doing that's all
i'm not going to be in touch with them i
just want to watch from afar i'm sorry i
was i think there should be a position
for every like in a relationship it
should be a standard yeah like hey
you have two ex-significant others that
you can follow i don't mind i have two
guys
i have i'll tell you what let me let me
hold this i'm gonna let's make this
i just want to know how they're doing
like if
if for some reason they have reached out
i can respond to tell you about it it's
not but it's but they never crossed the
line okay how about this i like i like
where you're going
it's a slippery slope because it would
bother me if the ann was doing it
but it would be cool it would be cool
like if i like there's two chicks
there's a couple checks
probably two i [__] know black perry
that like if they were having a hard
time in life i would like to boost them
and go just so you know you're a really
great person yeah like there's one chick
uh cash at them like five grand no no no
no yeah no no money can't get me wrong i
tagged them when i put myself on
pictures of private jets i tagged them
so they go this could have been you
don't forget
but uh
but uh hey by the way mike perry's
[__] awesome in real life
[__] is he dude he's so [__] cool
like he's chill he's casual he's he's he
really you is vetoes what's up who's
veto no i didn't say he went on theo's
punch i don't know a veto
i like [__] a lot like if
somebody's like okay man pick somebody
pick five people to be on your team i'll
pick mike
like skill wise it's gonna be a tough
night for him but he's a dog he's a dog
he's a [__] guy there's no question i
love that video you ever see that video
where he goes oh oh oh
daryl jenkins dog you ever seen that
video have you ever seen that video is
it's just some kid explaining his
football team let's put it out there
real quick
i think that mike perry is going to lose
so just for the record all this talk is
going to build up to this is the fight
we want to work but also my favorite
pocket i think mike perry is going to
lose
because
i think that uh my uh mvp michael uh
michael venom page is going to avoid
conflict he's he's too long and she
ranges
and i think that i think mike loses
michael i think platinum loses but
for the fight fan and for the for the
person that he is i really enjoy mike
perry i like michael vine page also as a
person
i'm just saying just skill wise you know
when you're talking about this yeah i
think mvp black and white mvp i mean was
that right
no not at all yeah shines no no i'm just
saying wow you're going through races
you're fine
so i think here's what i think he's two
there's so much razzle dazzle on this
guy he's so good bert really
special fighter oh yeah hey dude burt
wait tc
being in cyborg
yeah i was there i fought i was the main
main event of that fight i think main
event coming event something like that
watch this the dude's about to go in for
a shot right here
boom hey fracture but you can't do you
can't do that in bare knuckle right no
damage now champion came to throw okay
let me show them this that's it look at
his skull oh i saw that i saw that i was
there my son saw it right before i
fought and he was like dude i have a
picture of jacob my oldest son
and the stage is right here
joe you didn't need to say that big fan
already okay
so jacob the stage is here and i'm i'm
here and i'm facing him so i'm not even
in a bad spot i'm i have other dude up
against ali thompson have them against
the wall and jacob is so anxious he has
his hands like this and he's turned away
from the stage and he's not even
watching poor brother and dude he's the
only fight he's ever been to poor bubba
and i was like do i
was in london it was too much i couldn't
leave him at the hotel for eight hours
and i was like dude you got to come wow
so and what's worse dude what's worse is
think about this before you go fight
maybe on the same as when you go on
stage but before you go and fight yeah
you're not you anymore right like you
know you're a kid i'm pretty mean yeah
you're a killer like i'm a job job
that's not safe no no no no keep going
i'm a killer keep going so
so you're very similar
you're a killer um so i walk out there
and jacob's at the base of the walkout
and he's just standing there and i was
like dude so i walk up my rubbish i rub
his head a little bit and i shove him
all the way i'm like get the [__] out or
you don't belong here yeah you're too
cute yeah like you're not my family
right now george and isla during fully
loaded
they watched me tell the machine for the
first time
and aila kept going like this like oh
god no embarrassing
could you see well she goes she was like
i just was afraid it was gonna bomb i'm
gonna go baby it's a closer like they
bought our house we're fine
yeah
i i got this
i said to george i said what did you
think she goes it's [__] right
what the [__] you guys doing what are
you like the least what are you guys on
the internet yeah what do you guys
internet trolls
so um
what was i going to say goddammit about
michael von page uh
like world class like as far as striking
goes top 10 in the world
creative creative and athletic um i
think mvp versus izzy would be a great
fighter
i said that here did you we talked about
it before uh israel what did you say the
style maker sal bender makers style
bender and my mvp would be an incredible
fight saul bender's a cool dude he's
like a good funny guy on the internet
too oh for sure phenomenal and you know
what else dude
he wears his celebrity well
he's i watched him one of my favorite
things was watching him win that last
fight and enjoying it for like a couple
weeks yeah going around enjoying it
there's a tough fight coming up is that
pierre who beat them before
oh the dude who beat uh that brazilian
my hands are [__]
my hands are bisexual how funny is that
people want to talk [__] women men both
can get it bisexual
i do i i really enjoy michael perry he's
so funny man look at that bow tie is
vertical
[__] do you know how bad you [__] oh i
just noticed that
is that on purpose i hope it's an
accident but if not i like it you know
what i hate it
you know fashion better than i do i got
told by cigarette i got dolls up
basically you dress like a 13 year old
boy
i was like oh yeah maybe i do you know
what's weird actually i was talking
about i was like babe running they
changed my shirt she's like bert's
wearing a black shirt
because i had a black shirt too and
she's like don't you know what's about
tom tom's like crossed over where like
you know i don't see social media but
someone he [__] had a picture with
brad pitt
yeah like he's crossed over into this he
paid his hands
for that picture it was like it was like
a dinner i was like no it's
a fan of his isn't that nuts like bert's
gotten so big burton to tom tom yeah
yeah tom's still bigger than i yeah um
like size-wise but dude beside besides
rogue and tom's the biggest one tom was
a fat [__] for a minute tom tom
he's a big ass dude yeah he's done a lot
of things i saw i saw a
show i i since we're coming on i tried
i'm the
and tom was a big ass dude for a minute
there was a moment there was a moment
well
by the way it wasn't when he was playing
football no he when he was in his
biggest he was just like
yeah
tom's an athlete his dad his dad was a a
legit power lifter like i think world
record
olympic power lifter yeah thomas
gangster he's good looking dude now but
tom and tom tom after surgery like a day
like
i might i'm always speak in the fluffy
who wins mvp or or platinum mvp tom a
month uh i'm going i gotta go michael
michael perry i i just want my i'm gonna
go i want my go i'm gonna go venom but i
don't i want perry to win but i want
perry to win
only because i felt like him at times um
uh tom tom segura like a month two
months after her surgery was doing
deadlifts with [__] i still can't
surgery
what kind of shirt do you have oh you
haven't seen tom break his no no no
tried to dunk a basketball and his leg
exploded and his arm broke in half
because did he rupture his quad fat man
oh dude his arm is that what happened so
his arm
his arms
his arm's completely the other way and
bert decides to place it hold on you
tried to you tried to set his arm i
reset his arm like a professional
listen maybe it wasn't me it was it was
tom oh wait mvp is engaging
and by the way mvp is a big dude
he is a big dude his accuracy is going
to be a problem for uh yeah
and mike didn't have a whole lot of head
room head movement
wow i like that push away
i wonder if it's weird for him not to
kick
yeah pear's just a dog so you're gonna
have to hit him with a good shot to put
him out there's a lot of [__] that's
happened to michael perry's oh
oh
that's the thing about mike mike perry
does hit [__] hard dude
he's a grinder he's a great oh come on
man let him back again that was legit
that was legit no he wobbled him dude to
underestimate any
any
uh bare knuckle boxer's past is a
mistake on my part oh man
harry michael perry just seems like a
guy who we gotta remember do mike's
michael perry my platinum is a [__]
gangster dude that's the thing he's not
scared any hits
we were at a oppressor right and shannon
briggs was talking [__] to michael perry
you know who shannon briggs is yeah hey
come on champ
oh shannon briggs is a big ass dude
and he started talking [__]
he started talking [__]
that was a good punch he started talking
[__] to platinum and i swear to god i
told i was in the middle of an interview
i don't say hey platinum will fight that
[__] right now he's just a dog
right now that dude doesn't give access
that's his x factor in this fight if
you're gonna bet on him as a dog he just
there's no quit and he hits like a
[__] mack truck dude he's ended
[__] fearless he really
there's very few people you come across
in the world that like hey that dude
doesn't give a [__] he wants he fights
the way i want a microphone oh
like he fights like i want to fight i if
you put a microphone out you can't stop
me from getting on that microphone i
want you now if this is an mma fight
it's going to be tough for perry oh for
sure
that's uh yeah for sure with kickstarter
keeping distance yes uh but i'm gonna be
honest with you
i didn't know where that was going but
once you explained when there's a
microphone out there i can't wait to be
on it and express
that made a [__] ton of sense it's weird
it's weird to me that
people have that like oh there's this
moment let me get it yeah oh oh oh oh
it's the i've [__]
are you a karaoke guy uh
yeah yeah
you're a kid
so what's your karaoke song uh creed
higher
i thought you were cool before karaoke
really oh my god and scott stapp is the
baddest [__] alive i thought you were
cool on twitter
yeah i went to college with uh creed
well that sounds weird but yeah wasn't
he gonna commit suicide jump off a
building and i think ti saved him or
some [__] i'm a hollow notes guy
is that a different guy is that the
elite nickelback you're a rich girl i'm
not please google that
all i know is a chainsmoker kissed ti on
the cheek and t.i plus him in the face
so much
i understand social media says i can't
punch you but kiss me i punch you but
also what are you thinking
yeah hey dude mvp is so funny
dude
he's he goes from like facebook hold it
he goes
he jumped over back and fell 40 feet
fractured his skull and breaking his hip
and nose he credited rapper t.i was
saving his life saying i laid out there
for two and a half hours my guardian
angel t.i showed up immediately took
care of the situation saved my life look
t.i recalls the time he saves scott sapp
after suicide attempt tis might be a
suicide jesus christ
hey is he in jail t.i no no no he just
dm or text
tweeted me the other day i thought he
had uh i thought he had a felony charge
over weaponry what i'm hoping for me in
a heartbeat really are you [__]
kidding me hang out with one of the
greatest rappers alive yeah he's not
rapping i don't give up
what do you want for dinner a coke and a
joke and a little bit okay oh smoke a
joint and me and you i don't know if he
raps like that but sure
i'll go with it
um bring them out bring them out
it's hard to yell when the barrels in
your mouth hey dude so talking about
that the other day i was watching this
thing a real on instagram and it was
jay-z being interviewed and he was
talking about like how he hit like jay-z
now yeah and he was talking about how he
had to change his act and they were like
what do you mean had to change your act
he's like dude i had dmx
he's a guy
i got all gay backgrounds he's like i
had dmx open for me he's like and dmx
came out and it was like
oh my god yeah and it was like and it
was deep and the crowd was like [__]
yeah they said the crowd was so rowdy
and then they came out and started he's
like
and he's like dude it was so [__]
good
yeah the hard knock life for me so he
said it was so [__] grimy and then by
the time he came out the cold joint was
[__] men and wailing or [__]
jumping they wouldn't kill somebody
killing it [__] rowdy ass joint they
want to kill and then he ends and he
ends on a prayer right he's like blah
blah blah dear lord yeah and then jay-z
was like dude i've got to [__] change
what i do he's like i can't ever follow
somebody that crushes me imagine
dmx comes off shirtless and a pair of
overalls with timberlands on donuts
soaking wet and jc's in an eagles jersey
like oh [__]
beyonce's back there with him this
that's a great punch um one of my first
intro one of my most favorite entries of
all time i don't think i've ever been
punched like that you've never been
punched i want to try i have i have
once but like i like
legit that level of punch that i've
never received nor should you want to
bert remember when
frank muir has come out to frank mear's
a gangster friend right here came to my
house frank miller came to my house and
we had a cigar and then he looked at me
we didn't podcast amazing and then he
said i want another one can we do this
in like two hours and i went yeah and
frank muir showed up at my front door
two hours later he goes another cigar
and i went yeah and i it was like
meeting a man for the first time and he
has knives on them
guns
a good storyteller a dude that listens
and a guy
break you in half in a [__] heartbeat
monster yeah he they should have gave
him more of a chance at the ufc to be an
analyst i was so first of all yeah so
now mvp is dancing around a lot more
yeah his footwork's really good oh yeah
i was so impressed with frank mayer as a
matter of fact remember i told you the
card i fought on and trailer mike perry
was on yeah frank amir was the headliner
that's the one he lost yeah
and um but i knew frank from before
right just from being around that was a
great punch um is there something to him
making him chase him yeah because uh
because he can if mike if michael if the
mvp keeps going backwards he can pivot
he can he can position
well on
and all the kinetic energy comes from my
foot
to the turn right yeah so by him having
his hands down the plant on mike perry
coming forward allows him to plant and
rotate and turn himself you just gave me
enough information to get my ass kicked
in the olive garden
oh okay okay hands down did you get it
though i got it i got it but that's the
reason so mike mike perry wants to close
the distance yeah uh the mvp wants to
create so you'll see perry throwing way
more punches than venom but the reason
why he fights his hands down because he
knows that he's so quick
explosively oh mike oh mike perry's
venom yes
venom is an explosive counter puncher
mike is an aggressive puncher yeah
he's a dog perry yeah he's a dog once
make it ugly venom page wants to make it
pretty and keep distance yeah so that's
why mike perry's just going forward yeah
you see that it's hard you can't stay
back it's hard he does one thing and
that's i throw punches yes
now if it was mma it's hard for a kicker
to kick going backwards that's hard for
a striker to strike going backwards but
mvp is a counter puncher mvp is he all
do great going backwards
oh
that was a great he's starting to find
his spot yeah and he's so slick he's so
athletic he can turn his hips like that
so quick dude
he is athletic man
i dude ooh
mike's perry is [__] like perry's
lumped up huh how about bellator
allowing michael van page to fight you
know so i don't have many positive
things to say about bellator but i will
tell you this much
i respect the fact that um scott coker
is down is down for a hustle because you
know their main event fell through
and then uh david hayes who's uh you
know with all time greatest uh british
boxers
the main event fell through and he's
like i bet mvp would do it
and the owner did that's what got this
happening the owner of dave of uh bkfc
was like
michael van pager he's like y'all call
him and paige was like yeah i'm down
talked to bellator and scott cook was
like yeah let's do it but yeah dude he's
got this done this is a crazy question
really is there something about mild
afro baby afro yeah yeah is there
something about a fighter's skin that it
gets
uh like like more fragile the more that
yeah scar tissue nadia's because over
the years you're like the face of a
great white shark your skin gets real
thin because the scar tissue builds up
so yeah so you're more likely to get cut
um there's a lot of things you can do
does not look and is worried about his
jaw
there i've had that during the orlovsky
fight it's like uh you get like a damage
in the cheek and they can't go anywhere
so it gets really big
in your cheek it doesn't it nothing's
broke it just gets fills up with blood
oh and then it looks like he's swollen
yeah it looks like it's swelled but has
nowhere to go oh oh wow that that fella
like
my travis brown eyelid yes
i drink like mike perry fights sometimes
out of control
we'll deal with this tomorrow
uh yeah
i feel like you and i are ken and we're
gonna have the best time we are too yeah
uh about this uh frisbee golf um
i haven't played disc golf in a long
time but what's our guy who plays
frisbee golf uh fought jake paul ben
esquire ben askren's a bad boy hey dude
i've [__] enjoyed being asked
he's a regular he's a regular cool dude
i guarantee you like same music we like
too
you know how much afro you're the tattoo
on his foot don't you no live free and
be happy
a smiley face that says live for him be
happy
like do i [__] love the next day
quote uh no it's just just a happy quote
um but uh he was um i trained oh did he
catch him with that i thought he did but
maybe not um
i was training with him at duke rufus's
up and uh before i fought kimbo right
after i fought campbell one of the two
savage dude i didn't realize that he was
so strong in weird positions funky like
how did that create his own and dude and
he's so casually oh oh he's casually
elegant in a lot of things you wouldn't
expect him to be very smart dude yeah
very very smart dude
great person
kimbo is such a fun guy to discover the
best
i'm talking like like on the internet
tell me
sauce b
yep talking about slices
so on the show we're on the ultimate
fire together and uh me and kim would
talk at night and he's made like the
best barbecue sauce he'd take mustard
honey and barbecue sauce and make his
own sauce i'm like bro when we get out
of here we start making money i'll
invest in it you're gonna open up a
barbecue joint called slices you wanna
do it all in dade county texas it's
gonna be [__] lit how did kimbo slice
pass is that a heart attack remember it
was after that data 5000 was like four
or five months after that hey if you
pass me some ice hey if you're listening
to this and you don't want to die of a
heart attack go see a [__]
cardiologist yeah but if you're also
blood pressure but if you're listening
to this you're not going to die of a
heart attack come to my show in chicago
this friday then theater one show only 7
p.m in the heart of chicago the next day
i'm running the tough mudder 15k at 11
a.m come run with the thick boy
come yeah matt's not going to be there
but the rest of the thick boy staff will
be there mark harley will be there
running with me tough mudder is this
coming saturday august 27th and then one
show at the den theater on 26th and i'm
in appleton wisconsin september 8th
through the 10th ontario september 15th
through 17th boston baby laugh boston
september 29th through the 1st go to
burperberg.com for all those tickets
bert bertberg
bert three birds three birds all i gotta
do is think of a promo to do with this
big dance floor in my backyard oh yeah
[__] oh yeah you can write it off yeah
uh let's see your fully loaded comedy
festival is the september 2nd hard rock
uh are you talking about me yep first
interstate city center rock hard rock in
uh atlantic city are the tickets
you're in spokane great [__] it's
already sold out so is victoria so is
vancouver
so is vancouver so is vancouver so is
vancouver red rock so is red rocks
red rocks might have like 100 tickets
left cajun dome in lafayette louisiana
uh corpus christi fort worth lubbock
texas las vegas paso robles youngstown
charleston charlottesville
florence
charlotte hartford pittsburgh you do how
many shows a year uh a lot a ton
anybody i know no i don't know about
that who does more well i may do more
than them but who does more i don't know
your level
well i don't know i mean at your level
but by my level i'm still the level like
like chris uh porter probably does more
you know who chris porter or like or
like john heffern like there's a lot of
guys i just worked the way we used to
work when we did clubs i just do it at
theaters yeah so it's there's no
difference in the work load
it's just more fun yeah you know
porter's great porter's [__] amazing
monster porter is porter is one of the
most talented comics working without a
[__] doubt one of the best
storytellers
and so cool
fun to watch we're talking about jam
vans chris porter's like a jam band on
stage bro you know who's a monster and
last night it was uh trevor wallace
dalia
and then uh uh craig uh greg fitzsimmons
simmons had to follow dalia tilia
[__] crushed with his new stuff greg
fitzsimmons is doing something doing
stand-up for 35 that's what i said
simmons has so many golf clubs in that
bag bro that you're you forget how long
he's been doing it he
man handled that you got to think the
majority of greg fitzsimmons life on
this planet has been has been spent
thinking funny yes thinking funny so
when you just see him just god damn it
mike perry's a [__] gangster look at
him it's around five or five just see
him you talk only fans is a sponsor of
that you gotta respect that how about
that only fans check the killer
boyfriend did you see that i know
stab him in the neck [__] psycho then
they have videos of her like whooping
who won the elevator or she won
yes she won obviously
now only fans i bet you as a sponsor
because the co-main event that was was
pulled earlier this week was paige van
gaal and the girl she was fighting was
also known a fan sky dweller
is that it i don't know that's a cool
[__] five rounds five out of five
so if the fight's over yeah it's
do they do a bonus round or some [__]
yeah where they kick field goals
sudden death
oh that was only fantastic yeah she
killed him look how sad she is in that
mug chat
by the way
you see the video of her him her
whipping his ass in the elevator that's
what i'm saying the anti-ray rice video
yes
this dude she was whooping him what's my
rice doing these days
motivational talks oh for real
nope google ray rice check out his
website what is he doing oh my god he's
just broken hey
i know we didn't pay [__] worth
attention who won
uh
i i wouldn't be surprised if they give
it to [__] perry i got over to perry
because perry knocked him down he
knocked him down yeah only knock down
right yeah oh this is the fifth round
coming up
why are they they're doing that
wow that means that's pretty connect
that's pretty cool that's [__] dope
uh when i fought roy nelson the vagrant
uh in bellator it was during the
heavyweight tournament um
they had uh we went three rounds and
they were like hey uh they never brought
this up ever before never breached the
subject ever before they're like hey you
might have another round another round
to go so get ready and i was like duh
[__] like yeah it's a tournament
ultimate fighter yeah they're like it's
a tournament so you might get ready for
it what
how about this i'm so glad i held out
and held you [__] for ransom i'm so
excited
how about those do you ever see that old
documentary not old documentary but on
hicks and gracie where he gets in the
water
yeah but they are fighting like four
times in a night they used to back in
the day yeah not crazy nuts
yeah not anymore like i don't know
about i know enough about mma to
to confuse someone who knows a lot about
mma yeah for sure right yeah were you
ever have you ever grappled
uh no all right so
i mean yeah but no all right so let's
just let's [__] around let's be for real
no no [__] okay
you and me i i've trained a lot yeah i'm
not a grappler you and me get on the
ground start on the ground yeah how long
do you survive without being tapped
like because i'm not brendan brennan was
a black purple bell i know my answer i
know my answer i know my answer i got my
black belt brandon was the black belt uh
under henzo uh henner uh uh henry yeah
oh well henry and then also amal easton
who's a hanzo gracie black belt okay so
it's so enzo so brennan was a legit
black look they're [__]
ones they're banging right now i just
got it like
six months ago probably but you don't
even train one kid that's still real
yeah i didn't know that yeah do you
really yeah dude i haven't touched a mat
since [__] july 7 july 17th 16th i've
just met since july 16
of last year
would you would you say who do you roll
without here
uh guys actually where my son trains
just and then other black belts so
nobody real no no pros no um
uh dad i had the answer i i fought a 13
year old once
he tapped me in like
13 seconds wow
he trained he's a legit kid i think he
fights mma now did you ever see when cat
williams picked on that schoolyard yeah
this kid couldn't get his ass and then
his he had grass in his hair and he was
trying to defend himself with batting
gloves on yeah i did
you know what let me ask you this
question
and when i hang out with kat williams i
will not bring that up no no no no that
never happened so i saw a a a comedy
thing with him a handful days he was
like you guys seen where my life has
turned he's like i'm not going to judge
anybody so i'm assuming that's after he
got all [__] up so like crazy yeah
you want your heroes like that i want my
heroes like that i want
i want the [__] i want the fireworks
you want the madness i don't want to see
him light it i want to see it explode
yeah
when i die i want people to go that's
how you do it yeah yeah
i think you're on that track right you
know
you know but you know what that sounds
right cat will get beat up by that
fourth grade i was like that's not how
you do it well you know what you know
what what's up
it sucks but like
everybody who's worth their salt wants
to go out in a [__] blaze of glory
like i want to [__] like listen dude
shark attack shark attack i already
thought about me too
shark attack and i saved my family has
to be a great white guy i saved my
family and i pushed him on a surfboard
i'm like you guys get away i'll take it
from here hey dude yeah i got you baby
look at this mike perry that energy [__]
yeah you gotta love him i got perry mike
perry one i think so i got perry
he has the knock down
his face looks worse i give it to him
just on his face and he was moving
forward the whole time
i bet you venom page don't do another
bare knuckle no he went [__] [__]
this whoa look at him yeah yeah
hey dude i enjoyed just blood all over
him i enjoy him so much awful good
yeah can you imagine that dude did his
hair
i wouldn't do it for a ticket i wouldn't
do it for a ticket what's that what's
that a million dollars i wouldn't fight
bare knuckle oh yeah of course i would
not i'm in
bert you do that celebrity boxing [__] i
get my teeth removed
but it's my teeth is my weakness
no no you're irish that's the irish
you're irish right
yeah that's not your teeth you have
great teeth your irish no no no no
they're all fake i don't think i got my
he got hit in the mouth of a baseball
bat when i was 11. yeah yeah hey so i
might remember
my friend his face is pretty [__] up
so his fa like mike perry's face is just
going to go back to normal uh after
about two weeks three weeks yeah uh and
do you ever worry like when your face
gets oh yeah hurt did you go is this
gonna go back oh yeah
oh yeah
i have both my orbitals are broken i
have i really have yeah you wanna feel
it let me show you something no i don't
maybe well it's here
all right
so they're both exhausted what a fight
though here so run your finger across
here
okay yeah yeah yeah screws
oh they didn't want to feel that
i just thought we're gonna feel a bump
no no i got it i i would rather someone
fracture my orbital than let someone
chew back then
here
oh no no that's enough you didn't feel
it no i feel it no i did it it's cool no
ah it can't be healthy dude i feel that
one that's that's six screws there yeah
absolutely look at this look at this
blood just starts squirting out yeah
yeah
and his cheeks just filled with blood
right now yep it's just and what do they
drain it no it'll go down in about three
days yeah i think they give it to perry
huh i think apparently
i think you probably should but now this
is what i do if you have ocd bet
something on your life in your head and
you go
my mom's not gonna get cancer if my
periwins
biggest win ever for mike perry if i
took a uh a parlay a three fight parlay
i would have taken
mv peaks i thought he's going to fight
safe me too mvp
um
who who's the two big fights tonight
tonight yeah you got uh camaro usman and
and uh jose aldo no no no no uh luke
luke luke i'm thinking luke is the dog
okay
i think luke wins you don't think so
are you a fan of it are you cool you
know i love luke okay cool like yeah
luke's luke perry yeah of course you
guys uh yeah luke perry luke perry's
passport he used to live down the street
from us oh he passed away he's the
reason why i was comfortable with my
kids going to school they went to is
luke perry was up there
he'd be a drop-off every morning oh i
love you perry is a great dad his son's
an amazing wrestler oh really amazing
like uh uh like fly off the timber
blocks
i don't know i'm not saying that jim
cameron you know like a wrestler like a
wwe wrestler oh not like traditional
noise
nature boy nature boyfriend oh i i i
think you're talking about i think
you're talking about
like i was at usc wow boy in atlanta and
rick flair was there and the entire
crowd the entire time kept going
yeah that would be tough hey man can i
get a little something from my my for my
ringer sure he's like no i'm not working
oh wow
wow i think that's what i was the name i
yeah you know what fair point yeah he's
like no i don't want to do it he gave
him on the war and stopped one time
wait wait what do you think mike perry
is saying yeah a lot of something
fantastic here's my problem
hey trent
no way he's too much mike's too
dangerous for him way too disagree uh
are they the same size bert if i live in
the midwest where am i going to see you
at
i don't know how can we be friends if i
live in the midwest uh
by the way you just need to link up with
berlin torrey's on tour so much i'm
saying that's like where are you from
every week so i'm going to shoot my
special
in the midwest when you come into the
midwest like indiana illinois ohio iowa
where the [__] chin when you need them
kentucky
tennessee national she's taking the [__]
is it is it it seems like the fight's
over my job's done i'm out of here you
know he's like that's i'm clocking out
[__] yeah what i need to know is when
can we be friends again uh
by the way
we're definitely hanging out with you
the midwest has some killer [__] you
know pat mcafee
i do now i'm gonna be honest with you
guys
i'm gonna be honest with you
i love it i love
awesome pat's different
meaning
pat was real cool a while ago and then
you got famous and then things changed
so i'm just gonna throw it out there's
nothing like listen pat if you feel some
type of way then call him let's talk
about it but i feel some type of way he
didn't reach her my call either to be
fair so i feel like i still get calls
from him well you're a lot more famous
than me
you know listen he's got to clear up his
phone call off
i'm just saying hey matt
like making the heroes out of the zeros
i feel that like do i like pat i do like
pat i love pat but do i feel like that
hey man you want you want like you used
to be yeah i do feel like that well
you're saying do i like them i like pat
did he get did you get replaced with
aaron rodgers you think though right oh
no i didn't have a spot gangster move
yeah first [__] number in my phone
aaron rodgers noah his parents that was
so smart a-a-r-o-n
without even knowing cell phones are
gonna be around you will be everyone's
first contact i'm gonna name my kid
a-a-a
yeah yeah maybe you have
aaa storm chasers who's the most famous
person you have in your phone joe rogan
oh yeah i guess yeah you can't go wrong
with that adriana chechick
that's a big one yeah yeah yeah she said
tom and i could [__] her
dude
do it i i asked our wives and they said
no oh don't be a bunch of [__]
and then she's a double team double team
yes and she's and then we well we gotta
run it by our wives can't [__] other
chicks well and so so
i mean if you're gonna film it yeah
that's what i was like it's for a promo
it's only fans yeah and then she said no
they said no so we said all right all
right pivot what if we have
uh dildos on and we [__] her with dildos
and then they both said that's stupid
well don't worry but is it no i'd still
do it yeah and then
both our wives are like no and then
we're like what if we put them on
backwards
like their tails
yeah
and then tom goes and then what are we
doing i go jerking off furiously
so i've watched porn forever and forever
and i watched a flick this morning
because i'm away from my wife right so i
actually stopped watching porn the other
day why because i thought to myself this
is a bunch of [__] leanne won't do
it's just like watching that's why
you're watching watch it in the all-star
game and then go and lacing it up and be
like all right get ready for some real
[__] and i don't think so dude you know
what's terrible is i this is something
that we talked about before like don't
talk about this because it's gonna
happen at home yeah like
i can't do so any
my kids are gonna be so [__] mad
right now like dude so so kayla got a
modeling contract right underwear
modeling contract but i made sure your
wife did yeah okay i made sure it wasn't
thank god it's not your daughter yeah
i was like i'm just gonna listen i'm
just gonna listen to
she got that she got a modeling contract
for underwear whatever else lingerie and
i was like right well at least the
company's eastern european based i
wouldn't let him do it in america i
think all right so whatever so she can
do this thing here whatever else right
and then my son i posted it on my
instagram i'm really proud of you babe
good job whatever else but i didn't say
she had a contract i just put it out
there a couple pictures whatever else
and then my son calls me up last year
football season and he's like dude
what in the [__] is kayla [__] half
naked in the [__] internet for him
i'm like don't talk to me like that but
yeah yeah i was like hey we gotta talk
no now dude
of his stepmom and a thong
that's gonna be tough for a kid in high
school yeah and he's like
but she's like and i didn't think about
it because i i didn't i i've had a life
of this i never thought about like oh
[__] my kids yes and so and i was like
dude hey she got paid really well for
this thing but whatever else he's like
well if she got paid for it don't worry
about it well i already deleted them
whatever else so now like i'm at a point
where
in a speedo on roller skates that's a
tough thing
yeah i love for her this is what's
insane about
uh
my children
isla for her birthday for she just
turned 16. she's always said out of no
no one knows why she said this she goes
when you turn 16 you get the curse
that's not a rule but that's that's in
her brain and then she said it on
podcasts and like said it in instagram
videos or whatever so people have heard
it so someone hits me i'm turning 16
they're like hey ayla's on instagram
they're like eyla's got gonna what's her
first curse word going to be so we're
sitting there there's a
whole night
and i'm recording and we're having
dinner for her birthday i go ollie
you're 16. everyone on the internet's
asking what your first curse word is
going to be what it's going to be she
looks at leanne she sits next to next
and just goes [__]
kills it kills right
in the in the room and i post on
instagram my team
uh my social media people they post it
on tick tock
that night i'm asleep and it like
three in the morning eila wakes me up
she goes that needs to come down off the
internet right now three in the morning
what the [__] that's probably crushing
she woke you up 6.6 million views on
tick tock [__] and this kid says to me
the way your son says the way they see
the world's different than the way we
see they really do ali goes i don't want
to be a meme i don't want to be i don't
want to be the thing everyone does
voiceover to or they're like what's your
first word [__] and then every time
someone meets me for the rest of their
lives oh that's the thing they know oh
smart is you're the girl that said [__]
god they're smart and i went and i was
like can we wait till pre-sale is over
yeah could you just give me a daddy's
trying to sell out in new york yeah we
got some big red rock scissors
i just launched a tour i got a 200
tickets at red rocks [__] yeah
let's clean that clean i get a piece of
the rock let's lean this let's let's
look is that itching no more fights
there's no bonus fights or nothing i
mean as far as i know okay so
easy first of all uh shout out to my guy
in the middle chris uh lydon he's my
mentor he's been just little i know
chris i don't know how do i say that
oh yeah first day of i ever trained ever
chris i was michael that's your boy yeah
ever bull burp this is a blast it's so
much fun the best podcast i've had in
this uh i'm so excited to have a new
best boy studios thank you so much for
having me and and matt i think we're
becoming besties i'm [__] and i'm
gonna i'm gonna send you the grateful
dead dunks i'll send you pictures of the
colors you let me watch your color let
me know whatever oh you guys whatever it
is let me know my kids will be so hyped
dude so yeah i got you bert do we uh
you're in uh fully load comedy festival
there's tickets no no no no uh that's a
make up date fully load is lated
just all i care about hard rock two
shows in the arena uh
atlantic city september third september
fourth philly new jersey atlantic city
new york come out i will see you there
shirtless gambling all night long one of
the best i got antibodies [__]
let's party me too i got antibodies just
don't want to get monkey pox but all i
care about is next this coming friday
den theater chicago one show only the
thick boy squad will be there august 26
get tickets at thickboy.com and then
that saturday the 27th i'm running the
tough mudder use promo code team brendan
for 10 off to run with me and the thick
boys and then appleton wisconsin is
september 8th through the 10th ontario
california september 15th through the
17th
and then boston is september 29th
through october 1st laugh boston get you
some but chicago you're up this coming
friday den theater baby
we love you guys we're out burt you're
the best thank you brother
you